GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
I'M STATUS SOMEONE ASH KALRA
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT AND I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME EVERYONE TO OUR FIRST
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BEFORE
THE THIS SESSION ANDS I'M VERY
HAPPY TO HAVE A ALONG WITH ME
AS A MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND ON
HIS WAY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS. I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE NOTE THAT THERE ARE A FEW
MEMBERS OF THE LABOR COMMITTEE
WHO ARE VERY INTERESTED IN THIS
TOPIC BUT MOST OF THEM
REPRESENTS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND ANOTHER ONE OF SACRAMENTO
WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE ANY
LABOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS UP IN
OUR DIRECT ASSUME THE ALTHOUGH
SOME RICH YOU USED TO BE ON THE
STATE LABOR COMMITTEE IS VERY
INTERESTED IN ISSUES WHEN
POWERING WORKERS AND ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT
WORKS. FOR EVERYONE. I AM.
ADDITIONALLY HAPPEN THAT WILL
BE WILL BE G. JOINED A DURING
THE COURSE THE MORNING BY OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE CITY
AS WELL AS THEY COME ALSO I'LL
BE CERTAIN. TO INTRODUCE SOME
WE ALSO EXPECT THE SPEC BETTY
YOUNG WAS A DIRECT THE SENECA
COUNTY OFFICE OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT. WILL BE
OUT ALSO COMING IN THIS MORNING
AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO HAVE WITH
US TOM PIKE REPRESENTING
CONGRESS MEMBER WELL KINDA AND
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE ROSE
ROCK I KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU.
ARE VERY WELL AWARE THAT ROSE
SHOWED A GREAT INTEREST IN
SUPPORT FOR COOPERATIVES IS A
HAVING THAT STATE. FEDERAL AND
OF COURSE LOCAL SUPPORT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. ON ISSUE OF
THIS NATURE. AND SO. AS CHAIR
OF LABOR COMMITTEE ONE OF THE
AND I WAS VERY GRATEFUL TO BE
APPOINTED. IN THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR. BY OUR SPEAKER OF
THE AND ANTHONY RENDON AND ONE
OF ANY ADDITION TO THE- THE
HEAVY VOLUME OF BILLS THAT.
INVOLVE WORKERS INVOLVED LABOR
AND ALL AND AN EMPLOYERS. THAT
WE HAVE TO SIFT THROUGH. AND
HAVE HEARINGS ON DURING THE
COURSE YEAR. I WANTED TO HAVE A
LARGER CONVERSATION AND
SPECIFICALLY HOLD HEARINGS
AROUND THE STATE. ON THE FUTURE
OF WORK. AND IT IN MANY
DIFFERENT ARENAS AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE STATE
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS. BUT
WITH INFORMATION HEARINGS OF
THIS NATURE ON A WIDE RANGE OF
TOPICS BUT THIS IS THE FIRST
ONE WE'RE DOING ON THE ON THE
FUTURE OF WORK. AND I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE A GREAT WAY. TO
START BY A BY TALKING ABOUT
WORKER COOPERATIVES BECAUSE I
DO THINK THAT WERE COOPER'S
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE. IN A
MOVIE WHAT A IN OUR ABILITY. TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE SO
SUSTAINABLE WORK FORCE GOING
INTO THE FUTURE. AND SO I'M
EXCITED ABOUT DOING A DEEPER
DIVE INTO THIS AND FOR THOSE
THAT AREN'T AWARE INFORMATION
HEARINGS. ARE HEARINGS THAT.
STANDING COMMITTEES SUCH AS THE
LABOR COMMITTEE. MCCANN HOLDEN
DO HOLE DURING THE COURSE HERE
OFTENTIMES ARE IN STOCK BACK
MOST TIME THEIR SACRAMENTO. BUT
I'D MAKE IT A POINT TO TRY TO
HAVE INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. TO GET TO
THE COMMUNITY AND TO HEAR
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES FROM
AROUND THE STATE. OUR STATE IS
A VERY DIVERSE ONE AND WE
CERTAINLY. WANT TO HAVE A TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF PERSPECTIVES
BEYOND JUST OF THAT. ARE IN
SACRAMENTO OR OR PART OF THE
CAPITAL ENVIRONMENT. AND WHAT
WE DO WITH THESE INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS IS THAT WE TAKE THAT
INFORMATION. AND THEN WE USE IT
BOTH IN TERMS OF. OF CRAFTING
LEGISLATION. AS WELL AS BUDGET
ASKS OR IN GENERAL JUST TO HELP
EDUCATE. THE MEMBERS ALLEGE THE
LEGISLATURE ON CRITICAL ISSUES
THAT UP TO GOING INTO THE
FUTURE. THIS IS BEING LIVE
STREAM AND IT WILL ALSO BE
ARCHIVED I WANT TO MAKE MENTION
OF THAT SO THAT. I JUST SO YOU
KNOW THAT THERE ARE OTHER
MEMBERS AND IN PARTICULAR THEIR
STAFF. AND THE OFFICES THAT
WILL BE. PAYING ATTENTION TO
THIS AND I WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO GAIN FROM SOME
OF THE WISDOM OF SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION FROM TODAY. SO
IT'S THE REACH WILL BE FAR
BEYOND THOSE ARE SIMPLY IN THIS
ROOM. AND I THINK THAT. IT'LL
BE BUT I THINK I HOPE OF
BEGINNING. THE BEGINNING OF A
VERY ROBUST. CONVERSATIONAL
WORKER COOPERATIVES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND OF AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW THERE
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN A LOT OF
MOMENTUM IN SANTA FE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. TO ENCOURAGE THIS
BUSINESS MODEL. AND WILL
CERTAINLY HEAR THAT OF FROM.
OUR PANELISTS WE HAVE TWO
PANELS OF FOR TODAY. I'LL BE
WILL BE ADOPTED HER CARE ABOUT
WORK COOPER IS AND HOW THEY
GIVE WORKERS MORE CONTROL
INVESTMENT IN SETTING THE TERMS
CONDITIONS OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT.
AND CALIFORNIA'S IS CERTAINLY
HAD A COP CROSSROADS WITH
NUMEROUS SMALL BUSINESSES
PROJECTED TO CLOSE AS OWNERS
RETIRE. AND WE NEED TO POSITION
OURSELVES RESPOND TO THAT AS
WELL. I AND SO BEFORE I
INTRODUCE OUR FIRST PANEL A
LIKE TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO
MEMBER KANSEN CHU IF YOU LIKE
TO MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INSURED CAR
UP THIS IS REALLY A VERY.
TIMELY DISCUSSION AND I'VE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO BRING A
TROOP. OF A MY HOMETOWN HERE IN
HIS CELL SAVE. YOU MUCH YOU
MIGHT KNOW THAT BOTH OPTION I
SERVE ON THE CELL THE CITY
COUNCIL. WE OVERLAP FOR ABOUT
FOUR YEARS NOW WE'RE- VERY I'M
VERY HONORED AND HAPPY TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE. WITHIN SIDE BY
SIDE IN THE OF A STATE CAPITOL.
AND BUT THIS IS REALLY A VERY
VERY TIMELY MATTER BECAUSE- OF
A LOT OF OPEN. AT THOSE OLDER
GENERATIONS OF SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER ARE RETIRING. AND IN MY
CASE YOU KNOW ARE YOU GOT WHAT
WE BUT- BUT BEFORE I EVEN GOT
ELECTED TO SELL THE CITY
COUNCIL I HAVE A SMALL.
RESTAURANT BUSES AND I KNOW AT.
THAT TIME. MY CHILDREN'S. DID
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED OF
TAKING OVER A RATIONAL BASIS
THIS IS THE REAL GOOD TOUGHEST
BUSINESS. AND IN THE WORLD YOU
KNOW MAKE MY SERVICE IN THE
ASSEMBLY. LOADER COULD LOOK
LOOK LIKE A PIECE OF CAKE.
EMPLOYEES AND OF TWO SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND INSTEAD OF IT
BEING TAKEN OVER BY THE
NATIONAL A CHAIN OF BUSINESS
I'M LOOKING AT THE PANEL AYE
AYES ASSAULT OCCURRED NAMES ON
THERE I. SHE HOW DOES A SLICE
OF NEW YORK YOU KNOW I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO A TO MEET
YOU AND YOUR WIFE AS THE SANTA
CLARA I THINK IT'S TO RESELL
NEIL SO HOME. AND I'M I'M GLAD
TO SEE THAT IS BECOMING A VERY
SUCCESSFUL OF MODELS SO HELLO
THANK ALL OF YOU TO BE HERE AND
MANY OF THE STAFF. TROUBLED
FONG SACRAMENTO TO JOIN. US SO
WAS THAT AGAIN THANK YOU OFFER.
THANK YOU SUMMER SHOULD I DO
THINK THAT YOUR EXPERIENCE AS A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER ESPECIALLY
IN THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY IS
INVALUABLE AND HAS PROVED
INVALUABLE OVER THE YEARS IN
YOUR SERVICE IN THE CITY IN THE
STATE. AND I THINK ON THIS
ISSUE WILL CERTAINLY OFFER A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE THAT THAT
MANY OF US THAT SERVE DON'T
HAVE. AND SO I LIKE TO I WAS
GOING TO JUMP IN AND WELCOME
OUR FIRST PANEL AND I'M NOT
GONNA GIVE ANY OF A LONG INTRO
ALLOW ALLOW THEM TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES THE ORGANIZATIONS
THEY REPRESENT. AND JUST FOR
THE- AUDIENCE AWARENESS EACH
PANELIST OF BOTH IN THIS PANEL
AS WELL AS A SUBSEQUENT PANEL
HAD ABOUT. SIX SEVEN MINUTES TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS AND PRESENTS
AND THEY'LL BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS AS
WELL AS A FROM THE AUDIENCE BUT
WE DO HAVE. FOR ON THIS PANEL
FROM THE NEXT ROOM BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION A
LOT OF PEOPLE THERE ON THE I'M
DOING THIS WORK. AND SO. BUT WE
DON'T WANT TO JUMP RIGHT IN
AND- RIGHT INTO. AND SO. ARE
THE FIRST PANEL IS TO PROVIDE
BACKGROUND ON WHAT TO COOPER IS
WHAT OUR BROKER COOPER IS KIND
OF THE- THE NUTS AND BOLTS AND-
ON WORKER COOPERATIVES. THE
SECOND PANEL WILL BE.
PERSPECTIVES FROM FROM LOCAL
WORKING FROM LOCAL WORKER
COOPERATIVES. SO ON OUR FIRST
PANEL WE HAVE RICARDO NOON YES
OF THE US FEDERATION OF WORKER
COOPERATIVES AND THE
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIES
LAWCENTER. AS AN TRÊN HOME BUT
THE DEBATE. DEMOCRACY AT WORK
INSTITUTE. HILLARY IN. ABOUT
THE HILLARY ABOUT A PROJECT
EQUITY AND RICHARD HOBBS OF
HUMAN AGENDA SO BOOK. THAT IS A
YEAH WE HAVE IT WILL BE NO
RICHARD VERY WELL NOW FROM A
NUMBER OF YEARS LIBERTIES AND
HUMAN AGENDA. AND SO RICARDO
MONEY JUST. TAKE IT OFF. AND
LET'S GO DOWN THE LINE AS YOU
ARE PERCENT. THANKS EVERYBODY
FOR COMING TONIGHT LIKE TO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLOR
AND TO FOR MAKING THE TIME AND
THE REST ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT
AREN'T ABLE TO BE HERE. AND
FIRST I JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE
ALL THE LOCAL WORK THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON HERE TO GET US TO
ACTUALLY HAVE SPACE AND HAVE. A
VOICE IN THE COMMUNITY HERE TO
BE SPEAKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. SO AGAIN MY NAME IS
RICARDO NOON YES I AM FROM THE
OR REPRESENTING RIGHT NOW THE
STATE OF WHERE US FEDERATION
OVER COSTS I'LL GET TO THE LAS
AND IN A SECOND. AND SO. I'M
THE BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
OF WORKER COOPERATIVES HERE'S
THE REST OF THE BOARD WEIRD
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED. BY OUR
MEMBER WORK PLACES FROM AROUND
THE COUNTRY. AND THE US
FEDERATION OF WORKER
COOPERATIVES IS THE ONLY
NATIONAL GRASSROOTS MEMBERSHIP
BASED ORGANIZATION FOR WORKER
COOPERATIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES. SO OUR PARTNERS OUR
SYSTEM IS A- DEMOCRACY WORK
INSTITUTE WE ARE WORKING TO
CULTIVATE AN ECOSYSTEM. THAT
SUPPORTS THE GROWTH OF
DEMOCRATIC EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
AROUND THE COUNTRY. AND WHAT IS
A COOPERATIVE THERE'S DIFFERENT
TYPES OF COOPERATIVES IS
HOUSING COOPERATIVES CONSUMER
COOPERATIVES TODAY WERE TALKING
ABOUT WORKER COOPERATIVES IN
ALL TYPES OF COOPERATIVES ARE
GUIDED BY VALUES THEIR VALUES
ALIGN BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND WORKER
COOPERATIVES ARE DEMOCRATICALLY
RUN. WORKER OWNED BUSINESSES SO
THE MEMBERS OF WORKER
COOPERATIVE ARE THE WORKERS
THEMSELVES. THERE WERE
COOPERATIVE NATIONAL LANDSCAPE
IS THAT WE ARE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND WE ARE GROWING
SINCE THE FINANCIAL CRISIS IN
200-082-0009 THERE HAS BEEN AN
EXPLOSION OF KRISTEN FINDING
NEW ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO BUILD
EQUITY. ASSET LINK TO IN OUR
THIRTIES WORKER COOPERATIVES
ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO. ARE YOU CAN SEE
THAT. THE AVERAGE WORKER
COOPERATIVES PAY DOUBLE THE
MINIMUM FEDERAL MINIMUM WAGE
PAY MORE THAN THE CALIFORNIA
MINIMUM WAGE SO WITHOUT THE BUT
BY SELF ORGANIZING AND SETTING
OUR OWN TERMS WE ARE ACHIEVING
BETTER THAN STANDARD WAGES. AND
WE GET TO DEFINE THE RULES OF
OUR WORKPLACES SO WE GET TO
DEFINE DIGNIFIED WORKPLACES FOR
OURSELVES. AS FAR AS
DEMOGRAPHICS WE ARE THE FUTURE
OF WORK OTHER WORKER
COOPERATIVES SPECTER. ELITE ARE
PREDOMINANTLY. MEN AND LOVE
CAUGHT BLED AND ACTUALLY LARGE
GROWTH IN WORK PROPERTY
NATIONAL IS WITH IMMIGRANT
THIRTIES LOOKING TO FIND ACES
THERE WERE IN THE BODY THEY
CAN'T PULL THEM. THEY WILL BE
EXPOSED AT THAT CAN CONTROL
LABOR. WHAT INDUSTRY WORKER BUT
IS IT WE'RE IN ALL THE
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES IT'S GEN
THREE OH IT'S JUST BECAUSE
SHOPS AND BAKERIES EVEN THOUGH
I LOVE THOSE. THEY ARE IN AYE
IN CONSTRUCTION MANUFACTURING
RESEARCH AND DESIGN ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY. ALSO IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING YOU'LL HEAR FROM
THE SECOND PANEL ABOUT HOW
FUNDAMENTAL THIS SHIFT IN IN
PRACTICES IN THESE INDUSTRIES
WHAT THE IMPACT CAN HAVE ON ON
ACTUAL PEOPLE WHERE. FOLKS WILL
STAY IN THE FOOD INDUSTRY IN A
BAKERY FOR YEARS AND YEARS EVEN
DECADES BECAUSE AS OF THE
CONTROL THAT THEY HAVE OVER
THERE LABOR AND THE BENEFITS
THAT THEY CAN PAY THEMSELVES.
AND WORKER COOPERATIVES ARE NOT
A SILVER BULLET THEY'RE PART OF
A LARGER JUST TRANSITION WE ARE
WORKING WITH NEWS AROUND THE
CUT THE FIRE IS OF OTHER. TO
LEAVE THE LEG BE EXTRACTED A
COP ME AND BUILD THE TO SEE. I
CAN TELL TO REGENERATIVE STORE.
ECONOMIES COMMUNITY. AND ALSO
WORKER COOPERATIVES ARE NOT
FRIENDS ANYMORE WE HAVE
NATIONAL LEGISLATION PASSED
LAST YEAR THE MAINSTREAM PUT
PRESSURE BACKED WHICH DIRECTS
THE BUSINESS MINISTER GEN I AM
PAYS THEM I'M TO LAND TO WORK
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THEM GROW.
I'M A SECOND HAD THAT I'M
WEARING TODAY IS THE DIRECTOR
OF ECONOMIC DEMOCRACY FOR
SUSTAINABLE. ASCENT I'M HERE
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY A
DEMOCRATICALLY RUN ORGANIZATION
AND ADVISE OTHER NON PROFITS ON
HOW TO RUN DEMOCRATICALLY
THEMSELVES. AND WE PROVIDE
EDUCATION RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
FOR HIS ACCOUNT MASON SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO FIND WAYS TO CREATE
SYSTEMS THAT MEET PEOPLE'S
NEEDS ENVISION A DIFFERENT
CULTURE ALL THE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT WE ARE CREATING
IN OUR WORKPLACES IN IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND FINDING WAYS
THOSE LEVERAGE POINTS. IN THE
LAW THAT WILL ENABLE US TO MOVE
FORWARD AND BUILD A
REGENERATIVE ECONOMY. WELL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO
LEAVE AN EXTRACT OF ECONOMY.
AND WE'RE LAWCENTER WE LOOK TO
THE LOT TO FIND WHAT IS THE
EXISTING ACCOUNT BASED ON AND
IT'S A STOP. NEXT THING IS NOT.
VALUE FROM BUSINESS PEOPLE AND
GIVING IT APPS. DON'T PROVIDE
THERE MOST THE TIME DON'T
PROVIDE THEIR LABOR AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO SHIFT TOWARDS
ONE WHERE PEOPLE ARE
COMPENSATED FOR THE LABOR AND
FOR THE VALUE THAT THEY'RE
GIVING THEM THEIR WORKPLACES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND SO
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS DANIEL
ECONOMIES LAWCENTER WITH. A
HOST OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE TOMOXIA INSTITUTE.
WE ARE THE US VERY COOPERATIVE
HAVE AN LEVEL JUST LISTEN TO
THE FOR THE WAY TO CREATE. A
COMPLETE FINISHED IN ALL FOUR
SO IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE PASSED
A LAW CREATING THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKER COOPERATIVE CORPORATION
ACT WHICH CREATED A LEGAL
ENTITY FOR WORKER COOPERATIVES
IN CALIFORNIA THIS DID A FEW
THINGS BUT- ONE THING IT DID
WAS IT ENABLED LOCAL AND
REGIONAL POLICY ADVOCACY
EFFORTS TO ACTUALLY HAVE. GET
MOMENTUM AND HAVE A FOUNDATION
WE DIDN'T HAVE A DEFINITION OF
WHAT A WORKER COOPERATIVE WAS
AND SO NOW WHEN WE GO TO CITIES
AND ADVOCATE FOR CITY SUPPORT
REGIONAL SUPPORT FOR WORKER
COOPERATIVES WE HAVE A LEGAL
DEFINITION. AT THE STATE LEVEL
THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD FROM.
AND ALSO PART OF THE WORK THAT
WE DO IS NOT ONLY BUILDING
THOSE LAWS BUT ACTUALLY EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO SEE THAT ELVES AS-
THE ADVOCATE. ON THE ELVES AND
SO WE COULD AND WORKER OWNERS.
FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA. HELD
CONVERSATIONS WHAT ARE THE
AREAS OF THE LAW THAT ARE
REALLY IMPACTING YOUR WORKER
COOPER BUSINESSES AND SO WE HAD
AT WORKERS. COMPENSATION
INSURANCE CAMPAIGN WHICH I WILL
GET INTO RIGHT NOW WHERE WE
WERE ADVOCATING WITH WORKER
OWNERS TO CHANGE THE LAW FROM
SOME CHANGES THAT HAD DONE BEEN
DONE PREVIOUSLY AND THROUGH
THIS EFFORT UNFORTUNATELY. WE
DIDN'T GET THE EXEMPTION THAT
WE WANTED AND SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THE STATE CAN
PROVIDE IS. A WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE.
EXEMPTION THAT WORKS. THE WAY
THAT THIS CAN BY PORT IS.
MITCHELL IN FACT WE START
WORKING THESE COMPANIES. TWO
TWO FIVE THE WAY YOU MOVE
THERE. I DIDN'T ASK THIS TIME
BUT IT TO BE A FIVE P. THAT
WOULD CREATE A FRIENDSHIP
PROCUREMENT FOR EMPLOYEE OWNED
BUSINESSES FUNDING FOR STATE
CENTER FOR EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
AS WELL AS PUBLIC AWARENESS
PUBLIC EDUCATION AND ASSISTANCE
FOR CONVERSIONS AND WORKER
COOPERATIVES IN GENERAL ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BARRIERS FOR THE
THIS MODEL THIS BUSINESS MODEL
IS THAT PEOPLE DON'T KNOW IT
EXISTS. AND SO THE STATE CAN
REALLY PROVIDE A LOT OF SUPPORT
IN GETTING THE WORD OUT AND
HELPING US PROVIDE. SOME PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDING AROUND THIS MODEL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RICARDO I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME
WE HAVE CONSUMER JOHNNY CAM
THIS WHO WHO'S HERE WITH US. AS
WELL AS US LAST WALKER WITH
SENATOR JIM BELLS OFFICE.
CONNECTS. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS AN CHEN HOME AND AS A
SLIDER BEING PULLED UP BY MY
COLLEAGUE HERE. WHAT INTRODUCED
MYSELF WHEN I'M HOPING TO BILL
TO COVER IN THE NEXT SEVEN
MINUTES. I WAS ON PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE SHARED EQUITY
IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM. AT THE
DEMOCRACY AT WORK INSTITUTES
WERE MOVEMENT BASED THINKING DO
TANK COMMITTED TO EXPANDING
WORK ON A SHIP FOR COMMITTEES
MOST IMPACTED. BY SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY SO THOSE
ARE RECENT IMMIGRANTS SLOW
WHICH WORK FORCES AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. SOME HOPING TO COVER
TODAY IS A LOT OF GROUND. SO WE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT THE FEDERAL
WORK THAT'S HAPPENING WE'RE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT WHY WE EVEN
IN THIS ROOM BECAUSE A LOT
LOCAL WORK THAT'S HAPPENING.
AND IS IMPORT ROLE THE STATE'S
PLAY. ONE HOPING TO SHOW TODAY
IS A LOT OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING WITH CITIES IN OUR
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM. AND WHAT WE
LEARNED IN WORKING WITH CITIES
IN ADOPTING THIS TOOL AS AN
EQUITABLE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
TOOL. AND WELL HOW THAT'S PART
OF A LARGER CONVERSATION HAVING
ON THE COUNTRY ABOUT HOW CAN WE
USE WORKER OWNERSHIP AS A
STRATEGY TO. DO NUMBER OF
THINGS TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES
SO THAT WE CAN THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE WORK AND THE SAME TIME.
FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO THAT POINT WHILE
ADDRESSING. THE HISTORIC LEGACY
OF DISINVESTMENT AND
DISENFRANCHISEMENT FOR MANY
PEOPLE. SO THE SET IS SHARED
EQUITY. IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM. IT'S OKAY I
GOT THIS THINKS. ALL OF OUR
AGAIN FANTASTIC. BEAUTIFUL AND
EASY PEASY IS ALWAYS LOOKING
OUT FOR ME SO THE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM IS A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN ALL AND THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE OF CITIES. IT'S A
CESSATION OF MEANNESS
GOVERNMENT THE CITY COUNCIL ON
THE CUT. I'M WE CAN THE LAST
YEAR AND I DID FOR PLEASE JOIN
TWENTY COAL. ON TOP OF MY AND.
AND WHAT ELSE I'M ALL FOR
CITIES FOLKS DAHLE. VERSIONS TO
IMPLEMENTED SHIP HELPING
RETIRING OWNERS WE DO NOT HAVE
A SUCCESSION PLAN FORGOT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO SELL THE
BUSINESS OR EMPLOYEES THERE BY
KEEPING THE JOBS THERE. KEEPING
THE COMMUNITY INTACT ENSURING
THAT THESE EMPLOYEES NOW BECOME
OWNERS AND THEREFORE CAN HAVE A
STAKE IN COMMITTEE FOR THE LONG
TERM. THIS YEAR WE'VE PARTNERED
WITH FOR NEW CITIES TO WORKING
WITH LOCAL. RICHMOND VIRGINIA.
DEFINITELY GO AND INTENDED. AND
ALL OF THEM ARE JERRY KING AND
BANISH IT WILL BE MORE BROADER
THAN JUST HASN'T BEEN SHIPPED.
SOME OF MY LOOK A LOOKING AT
HOW DID YOU START UPS AND FOOD
ON SEVERAL SPACES. SOME ARE
LOOKING AT HOW TO USE EMPLOYER
SHOULD ACTUALLY CREATE NEW
FORMAL HOUSING UNITS SO. KIND
OF NEW FEEDING TWO BIRDS. WITH
ONE SCONE TO USE THE NONVIOLENT
ALTERNATIVE. AND THE REASON
THEY'RE ALL DOING THIS WORK
RIGHT. IS BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO THE
FROM TO. PRACTICE WHICH. BUT
SOMETIMES CAN EXACERBATE THE
VERY END QUOTE THE CITY.
LOOKING FOR TOOL THAT CAN
REALLY HELP THEM FIGURE OUT HOW
TO ADDRESS AGAIN THAT LEGACY
DISINVESTMENT AND INEQUALITY
AND IN AND IN THE IN THE IN THE
MEANTIME BE ABLE TO BUILD
ASSETS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY OPEN SURE THAT THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR STABLE
EMPLOYMENT AND THAT WAS **** IN
COMMITTEE FOR THE LONG TERM
RIGHT THEY DON'T LOSE THEIR
CULTURAL I TELL THE IF A LONG
RUNNING BUSINESS THAT'S PLEASE
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR DECADES.
YOU KNOW DISAPPEARS. SO CITIES.
AGAIN ARE USING PARTNERSHIP IN
MANY WAYS ONE WAS USING IT WITH
TOP PRIORITY. SMALL BUSINESS
CLOSURES SPENT ON HIS RIGHT HIP
HELLO PLEASE DO WORK ONE POINT.
HIS MIAMI SO THAT THEY DON'T
ANY OF THEM SHIP IT'S IMPORTANT
POINT HERE. MY IT DOES NOT HAVE.
IT'S A DIFFICULT CONVERSATION
TO HAVE GIVEN THE POLITICS IN
THE AREA AND YET THERE WILL TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
BUSINESS CASE FOR WORKERS
OWNING THEIR OWN BUSINESS AND
HELPING OWNERS SELL TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES SO THEY FUNDED THREE
LOCAL TECHNICAL SYSTEM
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO EARLY
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION WHICH IS
FUNDAMENTAL. TO THIS WORK AND
THE USE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANT MONIES TO CBG MONEY
TO HELP FINANCE POTENTIAL DEALS
AND ALL LAUNCHING AWARENESS
RAISING A BUSINESS OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN WITHOUT WITH PROJECT
EQUITY ACTUALLY. AS PART OF
THAT WORK. OTHER CITIES ARE
ALSO LOOKING AT EMPLOYERS OF AS
A WAY TO ADDRESS THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP. SO THIS IS A
HIGHLIGHT HERE IS DOOR ON
CAROLINA SO ALL THE FOCUS IS
ON. ASIA SHIP ALSO DEAL WITH
THAT IT'S. ONE OF THE BLOCK ST
STE. IN AMERICA. OVER A YEAR
HISTORY BLACK SUNDAY. AND
BUSINESS CLOSING EVERY TIME I
DO THAT CONNECTED SURE OF THAT
TO THAT LEGACY IN A MEANINGFUL
WAY I'M INSURE THAT AS THE CITY
GROWS AFTER AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
OF THAT GROWTH AND SO THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
NARROW THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP
AND CONNECT PEOPLE. TO GROWING
BUSINESS. AND THEN OF COURSE
CITIES ARE DRESSING IMMIGRANT
POINT. SO THE ONE CITY THAT
OFTEN COMES UP A LOT OF THIS
WORK IS BEEN DOING IT FOR SO
LONG AS NEW YORK CITY. THEIR
SIX YEAR FIND A- BASS YOU KNOW.
WE'RE COOPER DEVELOP ISSUE
FUNDS THAT SOMEONE IN A LETTER
TO FOR ORGANIZING AND GIVEN
HERE. YOU CAME INTO SYSTEMS UP
AND AN ONGOING SERVICES ON ITS
IN LARGELY THIS IS PART OF THE
YOU KNOW ANTI POVERTY GENDER
THE MAYOR AND OF THE CITY
COUNCIL AND IT YOU KNOW AS AS
YOU KNOW RICARDO SHOWED THE
GROWTH WORK ON SHIP IS WITH A
LOT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LOT
AND MOST NEW WORK OWNERS.
COMING ON YOUR CITY DO THE
FUNDING ARE WOMEN OF COLOR. SO
SOME EFFECTIVE CITY TOOLS THAT
ARE BEING WORKED ON SO. ALL THE
CITIES ARE DIFFERENT WHAT DO
GIVEN OUR POSITION. WE CAN
CONVENE WE NORMALLY AS IN WE
RESOURCE RIGHT. WE NEED WHAT IT
IS HAVE WE POUR UNDERSTANDING
OF THIS BUSINESS IT'S JUST THE-
CITY AND STATE. WHAT THIS IS
THIS IS NEED ONLY GIVEN BASIS
THE AGE OF OWNERS YOU KNOW
PARTICULARLY SOME OF EVEN THEY
DON'T EVEN KNOW THE INDUSTRIES
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES COMPRISE.
THIS IS NOT HOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
ABLE TO COLLECT DATA OFTEN SO
IF THERE'S A FOR THE CITY TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WORK AROUND
STRATEGIES ACTUALLY COLLECTED
SMALL BUSINESS DATA TO BE ABLE
TO TARGET. BUSINESSES WHERE THE
OWNERS ARE YARN MAYBE TWENTY
THIRTY FORTY YOU FEAR OF OWNING
THE BUSINESS AND FIGURE OUT HEY
DO YOU NEED SUPPORT TO FIGURE
OUT YOUR SUCCESSION PLAN WOULD
YOU BE INTERESTED IN EXPLORING.
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP. THAT'S PART
OF THE OUR RICH EDUCATION AND
OF COURSE COMES AFTER THAT AND
SO CITIES HAD TO WORK THROUGH.
OUTSIDE TACKLE SYSTEMS PARTNERS
I HAVE TRUST IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE HAVE THOSE. VERY SENSITIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THAT'S ALSO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS. TO
ACTUALLY HELP SUPPORT THE
CAPACITY OF TECHNIQUES IS A
PROVIDERS AT SUPPORTING.
BUSINESS OWNERS IN CONVERTING.
AND IT'S THE FINANCING WILL. BE
ABLE TO MOVE CBG MONEY FOR
EXAMPLE TO HELP FINANCE DEALS.
AND REDUCE BARRIERS TO THOSE
PROGRAMS. SO THESE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES I DON'T HAVE MUCH TIME
SO. I KNOW THAT ALL OF US I'M
SURE WOULD BE HAPPY TO SHARE
OUR PRESENTATIONS LATER ON BUT
YOU KNOW ALL THE CITIES ARE
USING A PLAN SHIP IT REALLY
NOVEL WAYS. AND THE COMMON
CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT
EMPLOYERS SHOULD HIS NEW MANY
COMMUNITIES. THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY VISIT MUCH BUSINESS DATA
THAT THEY CAN TARGET. IS A FUN
AND TING WHICH I'M SURE CAN
TALK A LITTLE BIT LATE LENDERS
OFFICIALLY SCOTT. WILL
FINANCING BUSINESSES MORE
OWNERS. CLIFFORD EVENING I'M
IS. WHO NUMBER. OF HE- COULD
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE IT IS TO. INCLUDE COPIES.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WORK IS I
DON'T HAVE THE COLLATERAL COVER
LOANS. AND THAT IS BECAUSE
SAID. CONVERT EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET. IT'S TIED TO ALL THESE
OTHER ISSUES. AROUND FUTURE
WORK AROUND PRESERVING
AFFORDABILITY. AND MAKING SURE
PEOPLE CAN CONTINUE TO. LIVE
AND THRIVE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND STATES AND
THIS IS MY FINAL SLIDE HERE HOW
STATES CAN SUPPORT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT SO RICARDO SHED A LOT
HERE AND I'LL I'LL. JUST ECHO.
NOTE WE NEED TO FIND. AND THIS
STATE OWNERSHIP IN IT.
CALIFORNIA Y. EDGY REACH OUT
AND IT'S NOT JUST WHAT IS IT WE
NEED HIM OUT COMMUNITIES IS IT
DOESN'T POOR IF NOT MORE
IMPORTANT ROLE COMMITTEES WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF BUSINESSES
AND ONE SHUTS DOWN. WHERE THE
JOBS GOING TO GO WE NEED
PROVIDE LOAN FUNDS LOAN
GUARANTEES INCENTIVES FOR
BUSINESS TRANSITIONS TO WORK ON
A SHIP THEIR EXAMPLES AND
STATES ON THE COUNTRY. YOU KNOW
IF YOU NEED TO DISSEMINATE
EDUCATION MATERIAL AND HELP
FUND WORK ON **** TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SO THAT'S
YOUR SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS THAT. AND NOW THE
MANDATE BY THAT TO BE A TO
SUPPORT OWNERS IN EXPLORING
PLANET SHIP. AN INCREASE THE
TAX ABATEMENT PROGRAMS FOR
GROWN BUSINESSES THAT WILL THAT
THE OTHER STATES HAVE DONE THIS
I BELIEVE IT'S MISSOURI IS ONE
OF THEM. WHERE THE HAVE
INCENTIVIZE THE CELL OF A
BUSINESS TO EMPLOYEES TO ENSURE
THE BUSINESS STAYS THERE. AND
PLEASE HAVE ASSETS IN FORD SO.
I'M EXCITED TO TALK MORE SHOW
MORE. YOU KNOW AFTER AFTER A
CONVERSATION. THINK THANK. YOU
SO MUCH SEN. HILLARY ABOUT THE
PROJECT. WE COULD SWITCH SEAT
YEAH YEAH. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARP
COLOR AND SHE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR HOSTING
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT HEARING.
IT DOES GET SITUATED HERE. I AM
NOT GOOD ON THE- SAME. THANK
YOU. GREAT SO I'VE I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN WORKER PROPERTIES
FOR A LONG TIME TWENTY FIVE OR
SO YEARS AGO I WAS A WORKER
OWNER AT ONE FOR ABOUT FIVE
YEARS AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THREE I'VE BEEN WORKING. WITH
REQUIRE DEVELOP AND. WELL I
HOPE FOUND PROJECT WOULD BE
YEARS AGO MY COLLEAGUE. TODAY
AND WE ARE GONE IN THE FALL.
HELLO HE'S EXTENDING RUNNERS
HAMMER MODEL WHICH WERE PRESENT
ON THE MIDDLE MIDDLE WORKERS
WERE BASED IN OAKLAND WERE
WORKING NATIONALLY AND WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THING
SOME SOME DEEP PARTNERSHIPS
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
CITIES AND ALSO EXPANDING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR WORK IS A LOT
ABOUT RAISING AWARENESS AND
BUILDING THE ECOSYSTEMS SO
WE'RE CURRENTLY PARTNERING IS
AND MENTION BUT THE CITY OF
MIAMI AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH.
HERE IN THE BAY AREA WITH
BERKELEY FREMONT AND SAN
FRANCISCO. AND WE SEE THIS IS A
VERY POWERFUL TOOL SO MOVING
FROM THE GREAT CITY ENGAGEMENT
WORK THEM THE GROUPS LIKE
PROJECT ACT I'M LIKE A
DEMOCRACY WORK INSTITUTE AND WE
ARE DOING AND OTHERS AS WELL.
TO ALSO ENGAGING STATES THERE'S
INTERESTING WORK ALREADY
HAPPENING IN DIFFERENT STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LOOKING AT THIS
PROJECT EQUITY ALSO. PROVIDES
FULL SERVICE SUPPORT TO
COMPANIES THAT ARE ASSESSING IN
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING
CONVERSIONS TO BROAD BASED
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP. AND WE'VE
HAD THE HONOR OF WORKING WITH
SOME COMPANIES IN THE ROOM
TODAY LIKELY KIRK FROM SLICE OF
NEW YORK WHO WILL SPEAK. ON THE
NEXT PANEL. I'M I'M ALSO
AFFILIATED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CENTER FOR EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
IT IS A FLAT AN ORGANIZATION.
SORT OF BORED IT'S JUST. GOING
BUT WE'VE PARTICIPATING ON
BOARD AND- I'M ARE ADDED TO.
THAT ORGANIZATION. FOR THEIR
MISSION IS TO WEAR A AN
EMPLOYEE. THE STATE. I'M AS
BOTH ASSEMBLIES MENTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MENTIONED WHEN
WE STARTED WE ARE FACING HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY
THE GLOBAL HE HAS ALL I'M
DEMOCRATS SHIFT NOT ONLY IN THE
I'M READ. THE ABOVE OUR FOURTH
OF OUR POPULATION NUMBER. SO
AGE WHAT TO BE BOOMERS RETIRE
IN SOUTH AMERICA THEY ARE
RETIRING AND THE WOMAN AND IS
KNOWN MANY TO SELL THEIR NAMI.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS THE
IMPACT ON BUSINESSES BABY
BOOMERS OWN. ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MRS IN OUR
STATE THEM BY ALMOST THREE
MILLION ALL. I'M IS SEE THAT
THEY'LL OF THIS COME THESE ARE.
THEN SIX IN. LIZ IS OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THE ANSWER.
ECONOMIC FORCE AND BECAUSE OF
MOST PEOPLE ARE HUMAN MOST
BUSINESS AND AS A HUMAN THEY
DON'T PLAN VERY WELL INTO THE
FUTURE FOR THE LONG TERM RIGHT
OR AT LEAST FOR THEIR
RETIREMENT AND SO MANY OF THESE
BUSINESSES ACTUALLY ARE
CLOSING. SOME ARE BEING
PURCHASED BY COMPETITORS OR BY
LARGER CORPORATIONS AND THAT
OFTEN REALLY UNDERMINES THE
LOCAL ROOTS OF THOSE COMPANIES
AND OFTEN CREATES LAYOFFS AND
OTHER OTHER CHANGES THAT ARE
NOT VALUABLE THANK NOT HELPFUL
TO COMMUNITIES. IT'S ACTUALLY
ONLY 15% OF BUSINESSES THAT
SUCCEED TO THE NEXT GENERATION
THESE DAYS. AND BECAUSE OF THIS
AND TIRING SIX OUT OF TEN OUR
PLAN TO SELL COMPANIES AND
THEIR NOT LOOK TO THE POTENTIAL
BUYERS UNDER THOSE UP RIGHT IN
OFFICE OR FACT BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE THEY WERE. EVERY OUR
POTENTIAL BUYERS AND AS WE'VE
ALL MENTIONED THERE'S AN
IMMENSE OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
CONVERT THESE BUSINESSES TO
BROAD BASED EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP.
JUST A BRIEF WORD ABOUT WHAT
WHAT WE MEAN BY THAT. BY BROAD
BASE WE MEAN THAT THIS IS NOT A
MAN BY THIS IS A BALLOT THAT
ALL EMPLOYEES WHO BASIC OF
OCCASIONS IN THAT ARE YOU A
FULL TIME REAP BURKE X. THE
WEEK BEEN WITH THE COMPANY AT
LEAST HERE. THOSE
QUALIFICATIONS. I'M NOT A
DEGREE AS- LEVEL OR YOU KNOW
MANAGE PROBLEM. I'M ALSO THAT
THE PROFITS ARE SHARED IN REAL
TIME BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THERE'S ANOTHER
MODEL OF EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
THAT DOES FOCUS ON RETIREMENT
SAVINGS WHICH IS VITAL THAT'S
THE SOP. AND SOME OF THOSE ALSO
DO WHAT ALL WORKER COOPERATIVES
DO WHICH IS TO SHARE PROFITS
EVERY YEAR WITH WITH THE MEMBER
OWNERS. THIS QUESTION OF IS
BROAD BASED EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
DEMOCRATIC JUST A BRIEF
REFERENCE IN WORKER COOPS IT IS
BECAUSE THE WORKING MEMBERS
CONTROL THE BOARD AND MAKE UP
THE MAJORITY OF BOARD MEMBERS.
THAT CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED ALSO
IN OTHER FORMS OF EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP LIKE THE SOCK. SO
VERY BRIEFLY JUST AN OVERVIEW.
HERE WHICH CAN TODAY PRIMARILY
ABOUT WERE COOPERATIVE. THE
BEST MODEL. DOCTOR PLAN IS
THERE ARE STEVEN THOUSAND
COMPANY IN THE CASE TODAY
PASSAGE PLAN. I'M OF A 100%
OWNERS. SOME OF THEM A SMALL
NUMBER BUT IT'S VERY POSSIBLE
THAT GREAT CREDIT PRACTICE INTO
SOME AS WELL AND THERE'S
SOMETHING CALLED THE EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP TRUST THAT HAS BEEN
PRACTICED IN THE UNITED KINGDOM
FOR MANY YEARS AND IS ANYWHERE
IN THE US THAT CREATES AN
ADDITIONAL OPTION. THERE THERE
IS QUITE A BIT OF DATA. I TAKE
THE- STATUS I THOUGHT UP
MANAGED TO. I'M IN MY OWN
BEFORE JACK DEPUTY WORK.
INCLUDE BUSINESSES HE IN THE
SEX IS THE BAY AREA THAT
WORKERS AND CALL BENSON
NATIONAL HEARING CENTERS A. T.
WHICH IS ALSO. A GREEN BUSINESS
AND DAVE SMITH MORRIS TODAY
FROM TEAM WORKS. I'M IN IN THE
ONES THAT WE WORK WITH WE
ACTUALLY RIGOROUSLY MEASURE THE
IMPACT ON FAMILY INCOMES
INDIVIDUAL WORKER OWNERS WERE
DOUBLING AND TRIPLING THEIR
PERSONAL INCOMES THEY WERE
BECOMING PRIMARY BREAD WINNERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND THAT WAS
INCREASING FAMILY INCOMES BY
FORTY TO EIGHTY PERCENT. SO
THAT WAS PROFOUND BENEFIT. FOR
LOW INCOME LATINO WORKERS HERE
IN THE BAY AREA. ALSO JUST JUST
TOUCH ON THE NEXT ONE STABILITY
FOR WORKERS IS ALSO PROFOUND IN
THE GREAT RECESSION. IF THERE
IS A NUMBER OF. IMPRESSIVE DATA
POINTS NOW AND THIS IS ONE THAT
THE LESS THAN 3% OF EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP EMPLOYEE OWNERS WERE
LAID OFF AND IN TWENTY TEN.
THIS IS 12% OF NON EMPLOYEE
OWNERS. SO THERE ARE MANY
ADVANTAGES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVEN AROUND THE WORLD FOR THE
COOPERATIVE BUSINESS MODEL AND
FOR EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP. A
DISTURBING HOME TO THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL YOU'LL HEAR
FROM A PANEL LATER THAT THE
MORE THIS. WANTED HIM TO
ANOTHER COMPANY. IN IN SILICON
VALLEY FLEET IN UNION CITY THAT
THAT WE WORK WITH. CHECK THAT
THE SURVEY GAS IS ONE OF THE
ELECTRIC ARREST RECURRENT.
ANGLE I'M WHO BECAME A CO OP.
ME. RIGHT IN THE PICTURE. TOLD
US SINCE THE- ADDED. TO HER. IN
TOTAL ON THE LEFT AND SARA WERE
THE ORIGINAL FOUNDING WORKER
OWNERS THAT NOW EXPANDED THAT
TO MORE. AND THEY'VE MANAGED TO
SHARE PROFITS WITHIN SIX MONTHS
AND THEN EACH YEAR THEREAFTER
OF THEIR CONVERSION. AND THIS
PAST YEAR THEY SHARED WITH US
THAT THAT PROFIT SHARING FOR
THE WORK ON THIS WAS A
PREVALENT TO FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR OF PAY. SO DRAMATIC IMPACT
AS THAT SHARING OWNERSHIP CAN
HAVE ON WORKERS. AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE I THINK MANY OF
THESE CONVERSIONS AS AS AND
POINTED OUT. OUR GOAL OF THE
ACT OF. KILLING THIS IS THE ONE
BY USUALLY WHITE MEN. TELLING
YOU BECAUSE OF COLOR OF ITS
WORK FOR THAT IN THE LOT
BECAUSE OF. THAT THE REPTILE
WELL CAP THAT I KNOW WE'RE ALL
CONCERNED ABOUT HIGH IT'S TIME
FOR ME TO WRAP UP SO I'LL JUST
MENTION THAT CONVERSIONS ARE
HAPPENING AROUND THE STATE. IN
ADDITION TO A SLICE OF NEW YORK
IN NILES PIE WE JUST CAN BID
ADAMS DIDN'T IT MOMENT. COMPANY
BURKE. HELLO SOLAR ELECTRIC IN
A ROOM PART OF THE- IT DOESN'T
BURDEN. PRISON PLEA INTERESTED
PREVENT PRIVATE IS OP AND JUST
TO WRAP UP I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT ABOUT WHAT IS THE
ECOSYSTEM STATEWIDE THAT COULD
SUPPORT THE GROWTH OF HER C<C.CYAN></C>
AROUND STATE AND THE ROCKETS
CONSIST. OF THIS MARKET YEARS
AGO AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WAS
THE INCREMENTS. I'LL MAKE A
MENTION IN THE HEALTH AND WE
ARE NOT SEVENTY ONE WITH FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS INITIAL CAPITAL
THAT IS A BILLABLE TO FINANCED
VERSION THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND IN ARIZONA ARE PUBLIC
LAUNCH OF ACCELERATING PLAY
UNDER SHIP IS HAPPENING. NEXT
WEEK AND LONG BEACH OR IT THREE
WEEKS FROM NOW. I'M SO WE STILL
NEED MORE FINANCING WE STILL
NEED TO UNLOCK MAINSTREAM
FINANCING. BUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
CONVERTING NOW WHICH IS REALLY
EXCITING. ON THE SENATE RICARDO
HAVE ALREADY MENTIONED SOME
GREAT IDEAS BUT THIS TICKET.
WENT OFF AT THROUGH THE RIGHT
HERE. VIEWS ALL FOR WORK TO BUY
THIS IS AND THEY GO UP FOR SALE.
AND HOW. IN WASHINGTON DC
RECENT LAW SINCE THE PAST I'M
IN. BUSINESS THIS HAS BEEN
PROPOSED YOU CAN ACTUALLY. IN
FRANCE SO THAT SOME INTEREST
PRESS THERE. AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED CONCERNED CAPITAL AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
SUCCESSFULLY USED WE OWE A
FUNDS TO HAVE CITIES AND OTHER
COUNTIES PROMOTE EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP CONVERSIONS AND OF
COURSE WE OWE A FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
STATE SO I THINK THIS PRESENTS
A REAL OPPORTUNITY. I'M AND
FINALLY WE DO HAVE A STATE LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM THAT CAN BE
USED TO GUARANTEE THESE
TRANSITIONS AND IF THERE WERE
WAYS TO MAKE THAT LESS
EXPENSIVE. FOR EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP TRANSACTIONS. MARKS
SELECT. AND I BELIEVE IT THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HILLARY AND NEXT UP MATURE HOT
IF YOU MENTIONED. GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M RICHARD
HOBBS IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HUMAN
AGENDA AND FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF HUMAN RELATIONS
AND CITIZENSHIP AND IMMIGRANT
PROGRAMS OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
THIS MORNING WHEN I WENT TO
REFINE MY PRESENTATION I FOUND
THAT BOTH MY LAW OFFICE AND
HUMAN AGENDA HAD BEEN ROBBED.
AND SO THEREFORE I LOST MY
LAPTOP MY BRIEFCASE AND MY
PRESENTATION. HAVING SAID THAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY A FEW
THINGS THE VISION A FEW MINUTES
CHEN AGENDA IS BASED ON AN
IDENTIFICATION OF HUMAN NEEDS A
COMPREHENSIVE IDENTIFICATION OF
HUMAN NEEDS FROM THAT HUMAN
AGENDA HAS DEVELOPED A FIVE
PART VISION. FIRST CARE WORK
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE TIME AND
RESOURCES TO PARTICIPATE IN
SELF CARE AND CARE FOR THEIR
FAMILY AND IMMEDIATE COMMUNITY
SECOND THAT PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OF. WAGES AT
WITH FAIR WORKING CONDITIONS
AND LIVING WAGE JOBS WITH
REDUCED WORK HOURS THIS IS
REALLY CRITICAL WITH REDUCED
WORK HOURS MAKING SOMETHING OF
VALUE FOR SOCIETY THIRD WE NEED
OPPORTUNITY FOR LIFE LONG
EDUCATION AND ACTUALLY CORRECT
INFORMATION. FOR ALL OF US NEED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN ALL OF THE ENTITIES THAT
WERE PART OF FROM THE FAMILY
ALL THE WAY TO THE UNITED
NATIONS WE NEED PARTICIPATORY
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS AND
FINALLY AT THE TOP OF MASS
LOVES HIERARCHY OF NEEDS IS THE
TIME FOR SELF REALIZATION OF
WHICH WE HAVE NO TIME AND
SILICON VALLEY. BECAUSE WERE
WALKING AROUND WORKING SUPER
HOURS AND SUPER ALIENATED. FROM
THAT. HUMAN AGENDA HEADS. ASKED
THE QUESTION HOW DO WE COME TO
THAT VISION AND WE DECIDED THAT
WE CAN NEVER REALLY GET TO THAT
VISION BASED ON OUR CURRENT
INSTITUTIONS ARE CURRENT
ECONOMIC. FINANCIAL AND
POLITICAL INSTITUTIONS WE CAN'T
GET TO THAT KIND OF A SOCIETY
WHERE ECONOMIC INSTITUTIONS ARE
BASED ON EXPLOITATION FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE BASED ON
SPECULATION AND POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS ARE BASED ON
CORRUPTION FREQUENTLY. THE
VALUES OF HUMAN AGENDA OUR
DECKS DEMOCRACY EQUITY CO
OPERATION KINDNESS AND
SUSTAINABILITY. AS A FREQUENT
SPEAKER AT CIVIC GROUPS I ASKED
THE QUESTION IF MULTINATIONAL
CORPORATIONS PRIVATE BANKS AND
OUR CURRENT POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
ARE DEMOCRATIC. EGALITARIAN
COOPERATIVE KIND SUSTAINABLE
AND PEOPLE WHEN THEY THINK OF
LIKE MONTH CENTER WELL FARGO
THEY PRETTY MUCH LAUGH. NO
BASED ON DECKS VALUES WE NEED A
NEW ECONOMY WE NEED A NEW
FINANCIAL SYSTEM AND WE NEED
POLITICAL INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
TRULY REPRESENTATIVE AND THAT'S
WHY HUMAN AGENDA IS SUPPORTING
WORKER OWNED COOPERATIVES
PUBLIC BANKS AND CORPORATE FREE
PUBLICLY FINANCED ELECTIONS.
WORKER OWNED COOPERATIVES ARE A
KEY ECONOMIC INSTITUTION TO
MAKE A TRANSITION TO A SOCIETY
BASED ON DEMOCRACY EQUITY
COOPERATION KINDNESS AND
SUSTAINABILITY. THEY ARE MORE
DEMOCRATIC WITH ONE WORKER ONE
VOTE THEY ARE THE EPITOME OF.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT IS
BASED ON PARTICIPATION. THEY
ARE MUCH MORE EQUITABLE WITH
DIFFERENCES IN THE HIGHEST TO
THE LOWEST PAID BEING ONE TO
TWO OR ONE TO FIVE FOR EXAMPLE
IN THEM UNDERGONE COOPERATIVES
IN SPAIN. WE KNOW THAT. PEOPLE
WILL NOT OVER CONSUME AND YET
THEY WILL HAVE ENOUGH TO. HAVE
A DECENT LIVING. THEY ARE MORE
COOPERATIVE BY THEIR VERY
NATURE THEY ARE MORE KIND ALSO
BECAUSE COOPERATIVE MEMBERS
THAT WORK TOGETHER MAKING
DEMOCRATIC DECISIONS IN THEIR
OWN WORKPLACE ARE ALWAYS GOING
TO PROBLEM SOLVE AND RESOLVE
THE CONFLICTS. AMICABLY. AND
FINALLY THEY ARE MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE NOT ONLY BY
OPTIMIZING INSTEAD OF
MAXIMIZING CONSUMPTION. NOT
ONLY BY REDUCING WORKING HOURS
TO ADDRESS INDIAN NATION BUT
ALSO BY MAKING ENVIRONMENTAL
DECISIONS THAT DON'T IMPACT THE
WORKPLACE OR THE COMMUNITY IN A
NEGATIVE WAY. THE LEGAL
COLLECTIVE OF HUMAN AGENDA
THAT'S DOING DEPORTATION
DEFENSE AT THIS TIME CLOUT ALL
IS OPERATING INSIDE A NON
PROFIT. AS A COOPERATIVE
IMPLEMENTING OUR DECISION
MAKING THROUGH THESE FIVE
PRINCIPLES IN ADDITION HUMAN
AGENDA HAS HELPED FOSTER THE
CREATION OF THE SMART GUARDS
COOPERATIVE AND IS CURRENTLY
WORKING TO DEVELOP OTHER LOCAL
COOPERATIVES IN SAN JOSE AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. THESE
INCLUDE UP PROMOTE OR UPS OR
HEALTH EDUCATORS IN GILROY AND
IN HOLLISTER. AS WELL AS THAI
MASSAGE THERAPISTS MY OWN LAW
OFFICE. AND A JANITORIAL
BUSINESS THAT IS UNDER AN ICE
AUDIT RIGHT NOW THAT NEEDS TO
FORM A WORKER OWNED COOPERATIVE
INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT.
BUSINESS MODEL THAT THEY HAVE.
IT WOULD BE WHO OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NO I WOULD SAY IT IS
ACTUALLY IN COME BEEN ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO CONSIDER
THE THREE OPTIONS THAT HILLARY
HAS MENTIONED AND IN PARTICULAR
FIND WAYS TO PROMOTE THE
CREATION OF WORKER OWNED
COOPERATIVES. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BOTH THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH FOR THE- VERY DETAILED
DESCRIPTION NOT ONLY OF WORKING
COOPERATIVES BUT- ABOUT THE
STATE CAN DO. TO SUPPORT THE
GROWTH OF BROKEN COOPERATIVES I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
ALONG WITH YOUR AGENDA THERE'S
COME FOUR PAGER. THAT WAS DONE
BY. LABOR COMMITTEE CHIEF
CONSULTANT AND PRINCIPAL
CONSULTANT MAKE ELAINE TO MY
RIGHT AND JUST DO A CRUISE SO
THAT'S IT DOES A REALLY GOOD I
THINK SYNOPSIS. OF BROKEN
COOPER'S AS A PERTAINS TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I THINK
HEARING FROM. OUR FOUR
PANELISTS WE GET A SENSE OF NOT
ONLY THE VALUE OF THE CROP OF
COOPERATIVES BUT WILL BE CAN
DO. MOVING FORWARD I IN AND WE
ALSO HAVE WITH US NOW ARE. I
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS WHO.
CANCEL REPRESENTS NORTH TO ME
ROBERT SOUTH OF ME SO SOUTH
COUNTY YEARS ANTI COUNTIES WAS.
AS WELL AS I SAN BENITO COUNTY
WHERE HE SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS WE KNOW. A LOT
OF THE COST PRESSURES ARE
MAKING VERY DIFFICULT TO
SURVIVE YEARS OF THE VALLEY HAD
BEEN RAPIDLY EXPANDING INTO
SOUTH COUNTY AND ASSEMBLY
COUNTY. AS OF THESE ISSUES OF
SUSTAINABILITY WORK ARE ARE
EQUALLY APPLICABLE TO SOME
THOUGH BUT WE'RE FORMALLY MORE
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE NOW
BECOMING LITTLE MORE. URBANIZED
AND SO. BEFORE ASKING QUESTIONS
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
ON. AND SO WHAT WHAT ONE
QUESTION ONE ASKED LIKE A LEAD
OFF. MISS ABOUT. IN TALKING
ABOUT THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES THAT COULD
CLOSE THE OWNERS RETIRED I'M
ACTUALLY. REALLY FASCINATED
ABOUT THE ABILITY TO KEEP THESE
BUSINESSES FROM CLOSING BECAUSE
AS WE KNOW IN FACT. ONE OF MY
STAFF MEMBERS FAMILY HAS A
RESTAURANT THAT THEIR UNCLE AND
HIS OWN FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
THAT IS CLOSING BECAUSE THE
KIDS DON'T WANT TO TAKE IT OVER
AND NOW A- A MORE CORPORATE
OWNED A BUSINESS IS COMING IN
ALL THE EMPLOYEES AND MANAGERS
ARE BEING. LET GO AND NOT
RETAINED AND SO ESPECIALLY AND
SOAK ABOUT I OFTENTIMES WILL
DIG IN A BUSINESS CLOSES IT'S-
SIMPLY BECAUSE RENT THAT
INCREASE WHAT BUT OFTENTIMES
ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSES
THAT COULD CONTINUE. AND SO.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY. DOES PROJECT
EQUITY DUE TO HELP IN THAT
TRANSITION YEAH. YEAH WE DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE BELIEVE IS
NEEDED. I'M AND THEN WE BRING
IN LEGAL AND CPA SUPPORT TO
SUPPLEMENT THAT THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE THAT WE'RE WE'RE SORT
OF THE GENERALIST IN THE
PROCESS WERE BUSINESS
GENERALISTS. THE FIRST STEP IS
USUALLY FEASIBILITY ASSESSMENT
AND THAT FOCUSES A LOT ON.
FINANCIAL FEASIBILITY
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH THE LENS
OF DEBT CAPACITY. BECAUSE MOST
WORKERS AS I THINK WE ALL WOULD
ASSUME. ARE NOT SHOWING UP WITH
A LARGE CHECK TO PAY THE. TING
OWNER FOR THE BUSINESS AND IN
FACT WE GENERALLY WITH WORKER
COOPERATIVES THE WORKER OWNER
BY AND THEIR INITIAL EQUITY
INVESTMENT. CAN BE PAID THROUGH
PAYROLL DEDUCTION OVER A YEAR
OR MORE BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T
SHOWING UP WITH A CAPITAL WE
KNOW AMERICANS. PEOPLE IN THE
U. S. DON'T HAVE SAVINGS SO
GENERALLY SPEAKING. SO WE LOOK
AT WHAT HOW MUCH DEBT COULD THE
BUSINESS POTENTIALLY TAKE ON IF
IT WERE TO BECOME A WORKER
COOPERATIVE THAT CO OP WOULD BE
ABLE TO POTENTIALLY GET A LOAN
FROM A CD A FIRE FROM A LOAN
FUND LIKE THE ONE WE'RE WHAT.
WE'RE LAUNCHING OR OTHERS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE. AND THE SELLER
WOULD FINANCE PART OF IT AND
GET PAID OFF OVER TIME. I'M
OFTEN WE'RE SEEING THE SELLER
TAKE ON MAYBE 3250% AS A NOTE
AND THEN THAT THE OUTSIDE
FUNDERS TAKE ON 5270% AND WE
NEED TO LOOK AT HOW MUCH DEBT
COULD THEY AFFORD TO TAKE ON
AND STILL BE A HEALTHY BUSINESS
AND STILL HAVE SOME PROFIT TO
SHARE. IN PATRONAGE DIVIDENDS
SO THAT'S A LOT OF OUR WORK IN
THE FEASIBILITY STAGE IS TO
ASSESS THAT AND THEN TO TALK
WITH THE OWNER WHAT WHAT ARE
THEY LOOKING FOR WHAT DO THEY
NEED WHAT DO THEY EXPECT IN
TERMS OF PRICE AND HOW TO THOSE
THINGS MATCH. AND WE ALSO LOOK
AT MANAGEMENT CAPACITY IN THE
COMPANY. AND THE OWNER OFTEN
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN OWNED BY THE SAME PERSON
FOR TEN TWENTY THIRTY FORTY
YEARS. SOMETIMES THEY HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED SORT OF A FULL
FLEDGED MANAGEMENT TEAM OR
DON'T HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS READY
TO STEP IN AND TAKE OVER THE
ACTUAL FUNCTIONS OF THAT OWNERS
STILL. DOES DAY TODAY SO WE
HELP THEM LOOK AT THAT
QUESTION. AND THEN WE PROVIDE
EMPLOYEE TRAINING AT THAT
STAGE. I'M IF WHEN YOU FINISH
THE FEASIBILITY IF THE BUSINESS
OWNER WANTS TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND IF THE BUSINESS OWNER WANTS
TO BRING IN PLAYS INTO THE
CONVERSATION AT THAT POINT WILL
HELP WITH THAT. BUT THEN WHEN
THEY FORMALLY BEFORE WE START
WITH THE COLOR BUSINESS
TRANSITIONS PROGRAM AND IT'S A
TWELVE MONTH PROGRAM OR LESS.
THAT'S VERY STRUCTURED. AND
WALKING THROUGH THE TRANSITION
UNTIL IT'S COMPLETE AND UNDER
THE CONCEPT OF THE RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL WHAT.
EXPECTATIONS ARE THERE ON THE
WORKERS SIDE. TO BE IN A
POSITION IN OTHER WORDS YOU CAN
SAY WHATEVER. PRESS FUSIL ROCK
SO YEAH WE WANT TO DO THIS. IS
ARE SOME OF THE IT TYPICALLY IN
THAT KIND OF. IT BACK ABOUT
POLICY EXIST WHAT KIND OF.
OBLIGATION IS THERE FOR
TRAINING FOR WORKERS ONE THING
TO BE EVEN LIKE A RESTAURANT
MANAGER OR LINE WORKER. TO
ACTUALLY RUN THE BUSINESSES.
AND SO. IS TRAINING OF THAT
NATURE. PART OF THE
UNDERSTANDING. THAT RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL ON THE CONCERT.
YEAH I BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD
BE I HAVEN'T SEEN IN SPECIFIC
POLICY PROPOSALS AROUND US AND
WE WOULD LOVE TO TALK. TO
ANYONE AND- I'M KIND OF. HOPING
TO HELP YOU THAT. FUNDING FOR
THE WORKERS TO PARTNER WITH AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE OURS OR
OTHERS THAT WOULD. BE ABLE TO
HELP THEM I'M- EXECUTED
TRANSITION RSS THE TRANSITION
AND THEN ACCESS THE TRAINING
AND SUPPORT THAT WOULD NEED.
BECAUSE I AGREE THAT WOULD BE
ESSENTIAL NHÀ. AND USUALLY
THOSE LAWS HAVE A SHORT PERIOD
DURING WHICH THE WORKERS IN
THE- THE TENANTS ARE ABLE TO
STEP UP. AND SO EVEN TO BE
READY TO LIKE THEY MAY NOT HAVE
EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT IT BEFORE
THAT MOMENT SO I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO. BE A VERY RAPID
RESPONSE YEAH. A GREAT I CAN AS
AN IN PLACE. DID YOU IDEA SORT
OF SOMEONE AS A BUSINESS AND
THEY WANT TO. GET OUT THE ONE
RETIRED I'VE YOU ALSO DON'T
WANT TO PUT OBSTACLES FOR THEM.
TO BE TRANSITION. THERE NEXT
PHASE LIFE AS WELL. AND IN A
COUPLE OF YOU MENTIONED THE-
STATE. OF THE OFFICE FOR
EMPLOYEE. OWNERSHIP AND THAT.
IT'S NOT CURRENTLY NOT STAFFED
AND DOES NOT BUT. VERY WELL
QUITE SIMPLY IF IT WERE STAFF
WHAT WOULD YOU WANT THAT THOSE
THAT THE STAFF MEMBERS TO DO.
IT IN AND HELPING EXPAND ON
EXPANDED SUPPORT WORKER
COOPERATIVES. THANKS YES SO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
COULD BE DOING ARE A LOT OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY DOING THAT WE THEN
CAN HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO TO
WORK WITH CLIENTS WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES TO REALLY PUT THE
TIME AND ENERGY INTO
IMPLEMENTING CONVERSIONS TO
HELPING START UPS. SO DOING A
LOT OF THE PUBLIC AWARENESS
EDUCATION ENGAGING WITH CITIES
WITH UNIVERSITIES WITH LAW
SCHOOLS HELLO A BIG BARRIER IS
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
MODEL IT EVEN EXISTS AND SO IF
THERE WAS A STATE CENTER FOR
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP THEY COULD
BE ENGAGING WITH. AT LAW
SCHOOLS WITH BUSINESS SCHOOLS
TO GET INTO THE CURRICULUM
UNDERSTANDING AND EDUCATION
AROUND DEMOCRATIC EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP AS SOMETHING FOR
THEIR STUDENTS ACTUALLY
LEARNING BE INTERESTED IN AND
THEN MOVE OUT INTO THE WORLD
AND BE SKILLED. SKILLED IN
OTHER THINGS THAT THE STATE
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP CENTER COULD
DO IS LIKE HELLER WAS TALKING
ABOUT HELPING TO IMPLEMENT THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO UNLOCK THE GROWTH OF
COOPERATIVES. SO WORKING WITH
THIS WITH THE STATE IF THERE
WAS A LOAN PROGRAM WHERE IF A
FUND THAT WOULD BE PART OF THE
RIGHT OF FIRST REFUSAL FOR
EXAMPLE THAT PEOPLE COULD TAP
INTO. SO STEWARDING THAT
SETTING UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND REALLY MAKING SURE THAT
IT'S NOT ONLY ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE STATE BUT ALSO ACCOUNTABLE
TO. THE LABOR COMMUNITY IN
GENERAL SO HOW IS THAT
STRUCTURED ITSELF SO THEY COULD
SUPPORT IN AND CREATING IN.
STEWARDING IT AS WELL SO
THERE'S JUST A FEW IDEAS. YEAH
AND I THINK ONE MODEL TO LOOK
AT IS THE RECENT REFUNDING
ACTUALLY THE MAIN OF THE
MASSACHUSETTS SIMPLY ENERGY
CENTER SO I WAS STARTED TO
BELIEVE IN THE LATE SEVENTIES
EARLY EIGHTIES WAS FUN FOR
AWHILE TO DO THAT TYPE OF WORK
TO RICARDO SPEAKING ABOUT AND
THEN YOU KNOW IS A IS A BUDGET
LINE ITEM THAT WENT AWAY IN
FACE OF OTHER PRIORITIES BUT
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY URGENT
ISSUE WHILE IN STATES ALL
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
MASSACHUSETTS REFUNDED THE
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE THAT
ASSISTANCE SO I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S A RESTORED THE CONFLICT.
THAT AND POTENTIALLY REPLICATED
HERE IN THE STATE. I WOULD
ALSO. ADD THAT WORKING WITH THE
LOCAL LABOR COUNCIL. THERE ARE
MODELS OF A UNION COOP
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. EXAMPLE
IN CINCINNATI WHERE STEEL
WORKERS IN THE RETAIL CLERKS.
HAVE ACTUALLY BOUGHT
BUSINESSES. AND ARE CONTINUING
AS UNION MEMBERS BUT ALSO
WORKER OWNERS. AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING WORKING WITH THE
LOCAL ORGANIZED LABOR THEY CAN
IDENTIFY WHEN A BUSINESS
CLOSES. AND THEY CAN MOVE IN
WITH THE RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL. THEY CAN HAVE A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY. TO KEEP JOBS LOCAL
IN THE COMMUNITY. AND NOT
DISRUPT THE FAMILIES THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD LOSE THEIR
POSITIONS. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT HAS ANY QUESTION WE
HAVE A COUPLE MINUTES. A FOR
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT OR QUESTION
ON THIS PANEL. I WANTED TO
START A BLOG WE'LL GIVE YOU CAN
GO FOR IT IS NOT THAT MANY
PEOPLE WE WILL JOBS LIKE IF YOU
GO TO SCHOOL. THEY WOULD TALK
ABOUT SIGN THANK YOU IF YOU GO
TO SCHOOL OR THEY WOULD TALK
ABOUT ALL YOU GET FINANCE FROM
A VENTURE CAPITALIST AND ALL
THAT I DON'T SEE A LAW THE
WORKSHOP. WILL MEET UP OR
INFORMATION OF ALL COOPER.
BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO
START. AND GET INTO IT BUT-
THERE'S NOT THAT MANY
INFORMATION ON IT SO I'M JUST
WANTING. HOW ARE YOU GUYS GONNA
PULL MORE THESE KIND OF LIKE
MODELS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION IS SOUNDS ABOUT WAS
WHAT WILL CARTER WAS TOUCHING
UPON IN YOUR COMMENTS THAT
THAT'S OF THE STATE. CAN DO A
BETTER JOB OF BECAUSE I DON'T
THE STATE'S DOING ANY OF THAT
RIGHT NOW. IS TO REALLY HELP
EDUCATE BUT THE COMMUNITY
EDUCATE BUSINESS SCHOOLS LAW
SCHOOLS. ON ON THE ON THE
DIFFERENT MODELS THAT EXIST IN
TERMS A WORKER COOPERATIVES.
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE. THAT
THAT THERE REALLY ISN'T
ANYTHING LEASE PUBLICLY. THAT
AS PUT OUT I KNOW CERTAINLY
CERTAIN CITIES OR OR COUNTIES
MAY BE DOING SOME WORK BUT- IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU LIKE TO ADD
TO THAT. IN ADDITION TO THE-
THE- PREMISE THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO DO MORE ON OUTREACH
EDUCATION IS. OR ANYTHING RIGHT
NOW WHERE SOMEONE'S INTERESTED
THEY CAN GO TO. I COULD HAVE A
THOUGHT. OF MITCH MILLER WHO IS
THE STAFF PERSON CURRENTLY
UNFUNDED OF THE CALIFORNIA
CENTER FOR EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS WITH ME ON
THIS AND- ONE OF THEIR GOALS IS
TO EDUCATE. BUSINESS SERVICE
PROVIDERS SO WHETHER IT'S YOU
KNOW PROFESSIONAL. ADVISERS
CPA'S LAWYERS. EXIT PLANNERS
THOSE TYPES OF FOLKS. I'M OR
SPD SEES THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS SO THE
GENTLEMAN MENTIONED SCORE. SO
IT WOULD REALLY BE A SUCCESS IF
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THREE YEARS FROM
NOW. ANYONE LIKE YOU SIR WHO
WENT IN TO TALK TO A SCORE
ADVISER WOULD AT LEAST HERE
THAT YES YES A WORKER
COOPERATIVE IS SOMETHING YOU
COULD DO I CAN REFER YOU HERE
FOR MORE INFORMATION. I'M AND
WITH THE MAINSTREAM EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP SB DC'S. HAVE A
MANDATE ACTUALLY IT ISN'T
UNFUNDED MANDATES SO ADVOCATES
LIKE US NEED TO REALLY BE
WORKING SO THAT SB DC'S KNOW
THEY- CAN BE DOING THIS THEY
SHOULD BE DOING THIS AND SHOULD
BE ABLE TO AT LEAST BE
CONVERSANT. AND MAKE GOOD
REFERRALS AROUND THIS BUSINESS
MODELS. THANK YOU SO IT YES.
YOUR EXPERIENCES WITH START UP
SORRY I'M INTERESTED IN START
UP OPPORTUNITIES I REALIZED YOU
KNOW A LOT OF ATTENTION AS BEEN
ON CONVERSIONS WHICH I THINK IS
REALLY VALUABLE AND GREAT BUT
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW WE
HELP IMMIGRANTS THROUGH THE CO
OPS AND WHAT YOUR EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN AT THE START UP LEVEL
ON BEHALF OF IMMIGRANTS IN
VARIOUS PROGRAMS. CAN YOU
COMMENT ON ANY OF THAT. YEAH.
YES SO THERE'S ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THIS THE SAME LOOK ON HIS
LAWCENTER PROJECT EQUITY WHO
ARE DOING WORK WITH DIFFERENT
TYPES OF WORKER COOPERATIVE
BUSINESSES AND THERE ARE
SPECIFIC ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WORK WITH IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
TO HELP THEM START WORKER
COOPERATIVES THERE'S THE TEAM
WORKS INSTITUTE DOWN HERE AND
THE SOUTH BAY THERE'S HUMAN
AGENDA THERE'S- A IN THE EAST
BAY THERE'S ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
SOME US MAYFAIR WHO ARE WORKING
WITH IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES HERE
IN THE SOUTH BAY TO EMPOWER
THEM TO GIVE THEM THE
INFORMATION AND THEN THEY PULL
US AND TO PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING. ONE RESOURCE THAT I
CAN JUST MENTION RIGHT NOW IS
THAT THE SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIES
LAWCENTER DOES FREE LEGAL
ADVICE FOR NONPROFITS WORKER
COOPERATIVE SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
THREE TIMES PER MONTH AND AT
LEAST ONE OF THOSE TIMES IS
VIRTUAL SO PEOPLE CAN CALL IN
AND WE CAN HAVE A VIRTUAL
CONVERSATION TO TALK ABOUT THE
LEGAL NEEDS OF MAKES
DOCUMENTATION. STATUS MEMBER
OWNED COOPERATIVES. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE QUESTION AND
THE RESPONSE EGGMAN INTEREST
THE TIME THAT WE WILL
TRANSITION TO THE NEXT PANEL
BUT WANT TO THANK. OUR
PANELISTS FOR GIVING IS A
REALLY GOOD FOUNDATION. ON
WORKERS COOPERATIVES AS WELL AS
WHAT THE STATE CAN DO A LOT
MORE OF. THANK YOU. SO UP NEXT
WE- HAVE A PANEL TO REPRESENT
WERE COOPERATIVES IN CALIFORNIA
AND A NUMBER OF LOCAL CLUB AS
WELL. IN OUR PART OF OUR
PANELISTS ARE AND THEY CAN DO
OF FURTHER INTRODUCTION
THEMSELVES BEEN INTERESTED TIME
I'LL JUST. NAME THEM AND WHO
THEY REPRESENT. KIRK BARTON
FROM A SLICE OF NEW YORK PIZZA.
SOUP AS SU LOPEZ FROM. OUR IS
MANDY. ASSOCIATION OF
COOPERATIVES. ELIZABETH
SARMENTO FROM SMART YARDS. AND
ROCK CHRIS IT'S YELLOW FROM.
NURSES CAN COOPERATIVE S. YEAH
YOU YOU H. W. AND SO KIRK
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY YOU CAN
KICK IT OFF. IT'LL BE THE SAME
A SIMILAR FORMAT BUT SEVEN
MINUTES UP TO SEVEN MINUTES FOR
EACH INDIVIDUAL AND THEN A
BEACON OF COMMENTS ON IN THE
MEMBERS UP HERE AS WELL AS
FROM. THE PUBLIC. GOOD
AFTERNOON OR MORNING STARK
MORNING USED TO GETTING UP IN
THE AFTERNOON. I SAW MY NAME'S
CURVE ARE TEN I MOVED OUT HERE
FROM NEW YORK CITY AND NINETY
EIGHT TO WORK AT HIGH TECH
CISCO LIKE A LOT OF TRANSPLANTS
DO. WHEN THINGS I MISSED
GREATLY WAS PIZZA AS A AS A NEW
YORKER AND WHEN I LOVE CISCO IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX MY WIFE AND I
WE OPENED UP A SLICE OF NEW
YORK OVER ON STEVENS CREEK AND
SAID. I WILL. ONE OF THE THING
REALLY IN BRITAIN FOR UP AT THE
CORE I WAS I WAS AT. B. C. B.
BEFORE AND THIS GIRL HAD
STOCKING YOU KNOW LIKE. YOU
THAT MUCH STOCK YOU HAD THAT
MUCH OWNERSHIP OF THE BUSINESS
YOU STILL FELT LIKE YOU HAD
THIS IS OUR COMPANY AND WE HAD
PRIDE. IN IN OUR IN OUR
BUSINESS WE ALWAYS WANT TO DO
THAT IN OUR- IN OUR
ORGANIZATION WE NEVER HAD A
CHANCE TO INITIALLY. IN THE
FORM OF STOCK BECAUSE OF TOO
MANY. WE DIDN'T KNOW THE
INDUSTRY AT ALL WE I NEVER BEEN
IN RESTAURANTS AND URBAN FOOD
SERVICE AND I'VE NEVER OPEN UP
A BUSINESS LIKE THIS SO. OUR
ATTORNEY BASICALLY SAID I DON'T
TRYING TO ANY OF THAT YOU'RE
ALL LIABILITIES AND YOU'RE
GONNA SET EXPECTATIONS OR
WHATEVER. BUT EMPLOYEE
OWNERSHIP IS ALWAYS SOMETHING
WE WANTED TO DO AND THEN. HOW
WE ACTUALLY TASKS SOME OF OUR
TEAM TO ACTUALLY DO A- BUSINESS
INCUBATOR BUT YOU KNOW BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT. AND WE FOUND A
WORKER COOPERATIVES SO I'M JUST
GONNA TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT. WE FELT THAT WERE
SUCCESSFUL FROM A TRANSITION
PERSPECTIVE SO THAT I. INSIDE
THE FIRST ONE IS. LONG TERM OF
THE INDIVIDUALS TIME BUYS IT IS
LONG THIS IS A STEPPING STONE
TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE OR WHAT
WHAT'S MY NEXT THING I CAN NOW
FOCUS ON A LONGER TERM HORIZON
FOR THE EMPLOYEES WITH THEM. I
HAVING MORE ENGAGED PEOPLE IN
THE ORGANIZATION WE HAVE
COMMITTEE IS WE HAVE BOARD.
FEDERAL IT BY THE NUMBERS.
THESE ARE SKI BUT YOU CAN BE ON
THE BEACH YOU KNOW OUR BUSINESS
SELF. CHART TOWN YOU KNOW THE
FIGHT IS LOOK IT WITH THE GOOD.
THE ACTION IS IN STRUCTURE OF
HOW THEY HATE ENTER WHAT THE
STATE PACKAGE IT MIGHT LOOK
LIKE AND I MAY I THINK I JUST
WANT WARM IT'S JUST THAT WE
STARTED ABOUT THIS TOWER HOW DO
YOU ALLOCATE RESOURCES IF
YOU'RE GONNA GET A PAY INCREASE
HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY FUND THAT
AND TO GET PEOPLE THINKING
DIFFERENTLY ON HOW THEY
APPROACH. THE BUSINESS AND THE
STRATEGY AROUND THAT. LOOKING
AT HOW THE COMPANY'S GOING TO
GROW AND WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS
AGAIN WE HAVE THE BOARD IS
INFORMED BY THE MEMBERS BUT THE
BOARD IS REPRESENTED BY THE
MEMBER ARAB REPRESENTS THE
MEMBERS ARE AT THE ELECTED BY
THE MEMBERS. SO THEY ARE THE
WORKERS THEY IT'S NOT LIKE
SOMEONE'S BROUGHT IN IN SOME
KINDA. OUTSIDE ORGANIZATION IS
LOOKING AT WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
COMPANIES THAT PEOPLE ARE
COMPANY AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
BEING INFORMED BY THE DATA THE
ACTUAL FINANCIAL INFORMATION. I
SAW THIS THIS MORE AS A
POTENTIAL. A CAREER PATH NOW
THIS IS BEFORE I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE SAW AS IT'S JUST A I
WORK IN A PIZZA SHOP AND YOU
KNOW I'LL DO WHATEVER INTO MY
HOOD. DOVE DO MY NEXT THING.
BUT NOW ACTUALLY ARE LOOKING AT
WAYS TO CREATE A MECHANISM TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO LOOK AT THIS AS
A LONG TERM THING OUT I DID
HAVE ONE LAST THING. THEY THEY
THEY SUPPORTED ME AS THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF PRIOR OWNER
WHICH IS. ALSO VERY REWARDING.
SO FOR OPPORTUNITIES THINGS
THAT TO THINK ABOUT LIKE
TRANSITION PROVIDES. I THINK
IT. CAN THE BILL. BENCH
STRENGTH. LEADERSHIP TEAM. AND
ALLOWS. TO COME IN. OUR TEAM.
ON HOW. HOW DO YOU. YOUR TEAM
TO THE NEXT. WHAT IS. NEEDED
YOUTUBE. HAIR THAT NEXT LEVEL.
I AM. NOT TO BE AROUND. ARE
THEY DON'T WANT. TO DRIVE
ACTUALLY IT. I CAN HIRE OR FIRE
BY THE BOARD SO I LOSE MY JOB
IF I START **** UP. AND SO PUTS
ME IN A LITTLE BIT MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY ROLE THAN WHEN I
WAS JUST AN OWNER BECAUSE AS AN
OWNER INDIVIDUAL OWNER YOU
KNOW. MY WAY THE HIGHWAY SEE
LATER THANKS VERY MUCH BUT NOW
I'M ACTUALLY I HAVE A
COMMITMENT TO OUR TEAM AND OUR
MEMBERS IT WAS YOU I ALWAYS DID
I DON'T YOU THINK THAT'S HOW I
WAS BEFORE BUT- IT TAKES THAT.
THAT CHOICE OUT OF THE MIX I
GUESS IT MAKES A LITTLE MORE
DIFFICULT. WE WERE VERY
EMPOWERED WORKFORCE WE ALWAYS
HAD AN POWER WORKFORCE BUT IS
ACTUALLY GIVES THEM THE CHOPS
TO ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING AND
RUN WITH THAT. AND CREATING A-
A LEGACY FOR NOT JUST THE
BUSINESS BUT ALSO FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE THERE AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WERE WE
SPOKE ABOUT. THE LAST PANEL IS
NEED FOR EDUCATION AND NOT JUST
THE EDUCATION OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE THERE BY THE
CASE IN THE DISTRICT. ANY VÀ
BRING PEOPLE AND SINGLE YES
THAT'S REALLY THE BIGGEST ONE
OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGED. SO I
TIMES TIMES TIGHT SO I'M GONNA
JUMP RIGHT TO MY FINAL SITE IS
HOW CAN THE LEGISLATURE HELP
LIKE WHAT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
ASKED WE CAN MAKE OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE FIRST IS
BROWN THE PROPOSAL GET IT. FOR
THOSE OF YOU IN IN IN IN
BUSINESS OR PERSONAL LIFE
PERSONAL GUARANTEE. THIS IS ARE
YOU HAVE WILL THROW TO. ACCEPT
THE. I AND AS IF ANY CAN TELL
US IF YOU HAVE A LOOK. THE
LANDLORD WANTS TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THEIR RAN. OVER TO
LEAST. THEY NEED A SINGLE
PERSON THAT THE VIEW OF CHASER
CITY MA'AM. CARE ABOUT HOW TO
FOR HER OWNERSHIP THEN SHARED
EQUITY THEY WANT A PERSON THAT
IS LIKE IF YOU'RE NOT PAYING
AND I'M GONNA GET YOU. AND SO
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HOW TO RESOLVE THAT AND DO
SOMETHING WHETHER IT'S SOME
KIND OF GENERAL'S FUNDED WITH
SB A WHO WHOEVER BUT THAT IS A
REAL ISSUE BECAUSE IT PUTS
INDIVIDUALS. CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS AT A AT MORE RISK
WHICH IS NOT THE PURPOSE OF
HAVING A COOP IS TO IS TO HAVE.
EQUITY IN RISK. AND THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY. IS AROUND
SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC OUTREACH AND
THIS IS. TALKED BRIEFLY. AT AT
THE LAST. PAGE AND I. CAN
ONGOING ABOUT REACH BUT I ASK
YOU. A LITTLE BIT DEEPER IN.
THE A PATIENT ON BUSINESSES.
LIKE OUR SMALL SAYS THAT HAVE.
OLDER ONLY. STEP THE OLDER
SHOOT NOW HOW OLD OWNERS.
LOOKING TO ACTUALLY MOVE ON
OUTLOOK DO THEY ARE NOW BUT I
MEAN YEARS POST OTHERS THAT
ARE. BUT ALSO. HOW CAN REYES
INNOCENT. GET EDUCATION AT AT.
LIKE WHY ARE KIDS BEING TAUGHT
ABOUT THIS IN SCHOOL LIKE HOW
CAN WE CHANGE THE DYNAMIC AND
REALLY IN BAD THIS IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM SO WE'RE NOT
LEARNING ABOUT THIS AS ADULTS
WE SHOULDN'T BE JUST LEARNING
ABOUT YEAH ONE LEARN ABOUT
WORKER COOPS BECAUSE- YOU MY
FRIEND JUST TOLD ME IT'S LIKE
WE SHOULD BE IN THE SHOULD BE
PART OF OUR CURRICULUM. AND HOW
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT I DON'T HAVE THE
KIDS BUT- HOW CAN WE GET THIS
AT THE AT THE GRADE SCHOOL
LEVEL AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
AND AT THE- AT THE- COLLEGE
LEVEL THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL SO I
WOULD ASK THAT. IS THERE ANY
WAY TO INFLUENCE THOSE
DECISIONS. AT THE AT THE
VARIOUS LEVELS OF OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM ON TO DO THAT. AND I
WILL I WILL LEAVE I'LL LEAVE MY
AND- BY A BY SEVEN MINUTES. SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
KIRK AND THEN. TO ELIZABETH YOU
CAN NOT SURE WHICH ONE WHAT
WHAT ARE THE CALL POPULAR MODEL
YOU CAN DECIDE WE WANT TO GO TO
EXPECT A. TO DECIDE AMOUNTS
JUST A HOAX. WHICH WOULD WHICH
WOULD WHICH TWENTY YEARS HERE.
THIS IS THE. THERE'S NINETY
THIS IS THE WORST THING. THIS
RIGHT THANK THREE VARIATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
I'M SU LOPEZ I'VE GOT ONE BIG
PHOTO SHARE WITH YOU AT LEAST
MOMENTARILY. I'M GONNA LET.
DEAL WITH THAT SO I'M GONNA
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
ARIZMENDI ASSOCIATION OF
COOPERATIVE MAY TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. THAT
BACKGROUND ABOUT THE NETWORK OF
COOPERATIVES THAT WE ARE AND
THEN MY PERSONAL STORY OF BEING
PART OF THIS COOPERATIVE ONE OF
THE BAKERIES THERE IS MANY
ASSOCIATION COOPERATIVES WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
NINETY FIVE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
IN A COOPERATIVE STUDY GROUP
CAN EVERYBODY HEAR ME. AND
THROUGH THE GOOD GRACES AND.
MAXIMUM A GENEROSITY OF THE
CHEESE BOARD WHICH IS A
COLLECTIVE OF A FIFTY ONE YEAR
OLD COLLECTIVE. BAKERY PIZZERIA
IN BERKELEY THEY HELPED US
START WITH THEM ACTUALLY
ANOTHER BUSINESS YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WE ACT WE COULDN'T FIND
FUNDING. THEIR BANK OR WE HAD A
LITTLE BIT OF FUNDING THROUGH
BANK BUT MOSTLY THROUGH THE-
CHEESE BOARD THEY HELPED US
TRAIN AT THE HELP THIS LOAN US
MONEY AND THEY HELP TO START A
WHOLE ASSOCIATION. CALLED
EHRESMANN THE ASSOCIATION OF
COOPERATIVES SO WE WITH THE
HELP OF THE CHEESE BOARD WE
HAVE JUMP STARTED TO HAVE. SIX
OTHER BAKERIES. THIS ISN'T ONE
OF THEM. THAT'S OKAY. WE HAVE
SIX ERRORS MANDY'S FIGHTERS
MONIES A ONE SHE'S BORED OR IN
THE BAY AREA AND WE HAVE.
RECENTLY HAS STARTED TO
DIVERSIFY JUST WITH THE SUCCESS
OF THE OF COOPERATIVE THAT WE
HAVE TO SEARCH STARTED TO
DIVERSIFY INTO DOING COOPER
CONSTRUCTION COOPERATIVE. AND
ROUTE LINE WHICH IS LOOKING IS
GETTING COOPERATIVE WERE ALSO
DEALING WITH A AT BUT KEEPING
QUAN COOPERATIVE. SO WHAT WE DO
IS WE HAVE A DEVELOPMENT
SUPPORT COOPERATIVE AND THAT
DEVELOPMENTS FOR COOPERATIVE
HELP SUPPORT. THE DEVELOPMENT
AND OF THE. FINANCIAL HEALTH OF
THESE COOPER AS WE HELP BUILD
COOPERATIVE AND DO JOB CREATION
SO WITH IN THESE BUSINESSES WE
HAVE NINE CO OPS EIGHT
BUSINESSES. TWENTY THREE YEARS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS AS A
NETWORK INCLUDING THE CHEESE
BOARD WHICH IS FIFTY ONE YEARS
OLD AND THE FIRST ARIZMENDI
BAKERY WAS STARTED IN OAKLAND
LAKE SHORE BAKERY. AND THEY ARE
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE A GROUP OF I THINK
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE ACRES I'M
PART OF THIS SECOND ARIZMENDI
BAKERY AND SAN FRANCISCO AND BY
GOLDEN GATE PARK. AND I'M ONE
OF THE FOUNDERS THERE SO THIS
STORY I THINK THAT IS IMPORTANT
FOR YOU GUYS TO KNOW IS JUST.
LIKE EVERYBODY YOU'VE HEARD
THIS MORNING THE IDEA. TO
NORMAL THE I. OF WHAT. BEING A
NORMAL THING. IN THE WORLD IN
THE UNITED STATES THE KIND OF.
INTERESTING I TELL YOU. ABOUT
MY OPERATIVE MAKES IS WITH
COOPER I WASN'T BEING BAKER HOW
MUCH. THERE WAS A COOPERATIVE
THAT WAS OPENING IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD AND YOU DIDN'T
NEED EXPERIENCE THEY WERE
WILLING TO TRAIN YOU SO I
DECIDED TO APPLY FOR A JOB NOW
NINETEEN YEARS LATER OUR
BAKERIES TURNING NINETEEN IN
OCTOBER WE HAVE TWENTY TWO
PEOPLE HALF OF THAT GROUP HAS
BEEN THERE FOR. NINETEEN YEARS
SO WITHIN THE FOOD INDUSTRY
THIS IS JUST THE KIND OF
REMARKABLE KIND OF STATISTIC
THAT NORMALLY ESPECIALLY IN A
BAKERY YOU KNOW YOU DON'T HOLD
ON TO WORKERS THAT LONG SO
WE'RE ABLE TO DO. TO HELP
PEOPLE THAT ARE INVESTED IN THE
BUSINESS. IN A COMPETITIVE WAY
WE'RE NOT A NONPROFIT WERE
REGULAR BAKERY AND YOUR INVEST
IN THE BUSINESS ENOUGH THAT IT
GROWS THE BUSINESS TO THE POINT
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP THOSE
PEOPLE THEY'RE LIKE WHY WOULD
YOU LEAVE THIS IS PART OF YOUR
BUSINESS SO WE'VE GOT TWENTY
TWO PEOPLE I GUESS ABOUT TEN OF
US HAVE BEEN THERE FOR ABOUT
NINETEEN YEARS WE SUPPORT
FIFTEEN CHILDREN. WE HAVE SEVEN
OR EIGHT HOMEOWNERS ALSO WITHIN
THE BAY AREA THAT'S REMARKABLE
SERVICES TO HAVE SEVENTY EIGHT
HOMEOWNERS WITH IN A SMALL
BUSINESS IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
THE BAY AREA THAT'S A VERY
MARKEL CYSTIC. AND AS WELL AS
IT IS. SORRY BUT THAT AS WELL
AS THE CHILDREN AND THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP WE TRY TO CREATE
A BUSINESS THAT IS COMPETITIVE
IN THE MARKET PLACE AND I THINK
THAT IS THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU HAVE A COOPERATIVE
COULD IN A COOPERATIVE YOUR
INVEST IN THAT BUSINESS AND
YOUR- YOU WANT THAT TO SURVIVE
AND IF IT'S GOING TO SURVIVE
THEM IS GOING TO DO WELL YOU'RE
GONNA PAY YOURSELF WELL WE- WE-
TREAT OURSELVES WELL. SO WE
ACTUALLY AS PART OF OUR AND
SOMEBODY MENTIONED THAT FORTY
HOURS A WEEK IS KIND OF NORM
AND SILICON VALLEY IS PROBABLY
MORE THAN THAT OURS IS A LITTLE
BIT LESS WE DO. THREE TO FOUR
SHIFTS A WEEK WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY SIX TO SEVEN
WEEKS VACATION WE TREAT
OURSELVES WELL AS I'M SAYING
WHICH IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART OF THE COOP BECAUSE THEN
YOU KEEP PEOPLE IN THE COOP AND
USE CONTINUE TO BILL THAT
CAUGHT OUR COOPS THE FAMILY
COUGHS PAY FEES INTO A POT TO
HELP DEVELOP OTHER
COOPERATIVES. AND. THAT'S WHAT
WE DO AS PART OF A NETWORK. IF
THERE WAS OTHER FINDING I MEAN
WITH IN TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT WE
HAVE ABOUT TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT ARE PART OF THIS.
FAMILY OF COOPERATIVES BUT- YOU
CAN IMAGINE IF THERE WAS A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF A GRAND
SCALE OF SUPPORT. OF THE AMOUNT
OF CAPACITY THAT WE COULD REACH
FOR AS WELL WOULD BE THAT MUCH
MORE. AND ALSO I WANTED TO
MENTION AS FAR AS NORMALIZING
THE IDEA OF COOPERATIVES AND
KIND OF GETTING AWAY OF THAT
STERRY TO GET AWAY FROM THE
STEREOTYPE OF SOMETHING THAT'S
KIND OF LIKE A HIPPY DIPPY
THING. I WANT TO KIND OF MAKE
THE POINT THAT LIKE YOU KNOW
THE CLOCKS IT'S NOT THE ROSE
COLORED GLASSES AS FAR AS LIKE
EVERYTHING'S OKEY DOKEY WITH
COPS AND WE ALL. LOVE EACH
OTHER AND LIVE IN THE SAME
HOUSE AND DO EVERYTHING
TOGETHER COULD MEALS TOGETHER.
IT'S A NORMAL BUSINESS WE HAVE.
INTENSE DISCUSSIONS OF THAT
LEAD TO INTENSE ARGUMENTS THAT
LEAD TO VERY LONG MEDIANS BUT
IT'S ONE PERSON ONE VOTE. WHEN
I FIRST YOU KNOW WAS TALKING TO
AT KIRK ABOUT. YOU KNOW I WAS
REACHING OUT TO FOLKS WERE LIKE
WHY IS THIS LET NOT A NORMAL
THING. BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHEN
YOUR KID. YOU'RE EXCITED TO GET
THE CHANCE TO VOTE YOU TURN
EIGHTEEN YOU GET TO VOTE THEN
YOU BECOME AND EMPLOYEES
SOMEPLACE. AND YOU DON'T HAVE A
SAY. AND WHAT COMES TO WHAT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT PART IS
THAT. CO OPS EVEN IF IT'S A
DYSFUNCTIONAL COP IT'S A COOP
AND YOU HAVE A SAY. IN THAT AND
YOU HAVE YOU HAVE A VOICE TO
TRY TO. COOPER OVER. KIND OF
JOB BECAUSE AT LEAST HAVE A
VOICE AND YOU HAVE SOME AGENCY
TO TRY TO MAKE SOMETHING. I
THINK THAT IS WHAT'S MORE
NORMAL ABOUT COOPS IN OTHER
COUNTRIES WERE PEOPLE SAY ALL
OF THIS CALL THE BACKUP IS LIKE
WHATEVER WHATEVER. IT THAT IT'S
JUST KIND OF YOU KNOW IT'S PART
OF LIFE IT'S THIS BUSINESS OF
THAT BUSINESS IT'S COOPS COULD
BE GREAT COPS ARE NOT GREAT
COPS BUT IT'S A COOP AND YOU
HAVE AGENCY TO CREATE. THAT
WITH YOUR VOICE IN WITH YOUR
VOTE AND THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT I FEEL.
COULD BE SHARED AND FOR PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE A CO OP AND YOUR
STEWARDING AN ORGANIZATION THAT
IT'S NOT I MEAN YOU'RE DOING
WELL BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING MORE
FOR YOURSELF AND YOUR DOING
WELL FOR YOUR COMMUNITY TO MAKE
THAT BUSINESS THRIVE. AND
YOU'RE ALSO LOOKING FORWARD FOR
THAT BUSINESS TO MOVE FORWARD.
BEYOND YOUR. WITHOUT BEYOND
YOUR TIME THERE SO WE TRY TO
KIND OF SEE THAT AS KIND OF A
LEGACY THING WITH AND OUR
NETWORKING WITHIN OUR
ASSOCIATION AND OUR
COOPERATIVES IT THEMSELVES. AND
I HOPE THAT IDEA. THE KIND OF
GET AWAY FROM LIKE I SAID LIKE
SAID. TO KIND OF GET AWAY FROM
THE IDEA OF COOPS KIND OF BEING
UNDER ASSAULT BUT IT JUST IT'S
NORMAL IT'S YOU KNOW THE
CONVERSATION TO COMPROMISE THE
COMMUNICATION. AS LONG AS
EVERYBODY HAS A VOTE I THINK
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
AND WE KNOW THE ONE PERSON ONE
VOTE. IN THE UNITED STATES
WOULD BE IN A DIFFERENT
SITUATION RIGHT NOW FOR WAS ONE
PERSON ONE VOTE. THE POPULAR
VOTE IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING. SO. YOU KNOW I DON'T
HAVE TOO MUCH AS TO SHARE I'M
SORRY I HAVE TO MANY DIDACTICS
FOR YOU GUYS BUT- THAT THE
GROUP OF MY- THE GROUP. OF
FOLKS THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH FOR NINETEEN YEARS. AND
YEAH I HOPE THAT. EVERYBODY
KINDA LOOKS FORWARD INTO KIND
OF EXPANDING COOPS TO BE JUST A
NORMAL PART OF THE BUSINESS
LANDSCAPE I THINK THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING. IT'S JUST
YOU'VE GOT YOUR LL SEE YOU GOT
YOUR WALMART YOU GOT THIS YOU
GOT THAT AND YOU GET YOUR CALL
UPS AND IT'S A NORMAL THING. SO
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT I'M HOPING
FOR IN MY LIFETIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE SUIT. NEXT UP A
LIST OF THIS I'M INTO WITH THE
SMART YARDS. DO YOU WANT ME TO.
WHAT IS. STARS I WANT TO FIRST
US THEY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. THANK YOU CAN HIT
THE BUTTON. AT THE BOTTOM.
FIRST I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I ASK ARE ALL
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANKS TO THE REST
OF THE COMMITTEE AND TO MEGAN
LANE AND JUSTIN WHO BROUGHT US
HERE TOGETHER AND ORGANIZE THIS
AND TO ALL OF YOU FOR BEING
HERE THIS MORNING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH ADAM ANT THOUGH AND I
AM US MY ARTS CALL UP BASED
HERE IN SAN JOSE MANAGER. AND
ACTUALLY I WANT TO ALSO THANK
THE AS MY ARTS EDUCATION BOARD
ROB YANAGI THAT WAS HERE TODAY
OF LIANNA ROSE MAN DOC ROBERT
AT BILL WRUBEL AND DAY OUT
THANK YOU COMMENT. OF. IN THE
SO. THEY ARE. FIND THE RIGHT I
GOT IT. STILL WE ARE SMART ****
LUNCH AND OCTOBER TWENTY
FIFTEENTH OCTOBER FIFTEENTH
TWENTY FIFTEENTH WITH A GROUP
OF. SIXTY ARE. IN THE SUMMER UP
THE SUPPORT OF A HUMAN AND THE.
AND ALSO THEM ENVIRONMENTALIST.
OF THIS. AND I'M GOING TO TELL
YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT AND ALSO
OF COURSE HUMAN AGENDA WAS THE
INK WHO STARTED OUT HELP A
INCUBATE US MY ARTS THE MISSION
OF MY ARTS GO UP IS TO
TRANSFORM. YARDS INTO OUR
BEAUTIFUL. DOORLY THIS IS THE
PROVIDE A LOGICAL. SAFE WATER
ENERGY AND ARE FINE BASE WERE
UP I'M SINGLE MAYBE TO ENJOY IT
I'M SAME TIME. ECONOMICALLY
EMPOWER THE MEMBERS. WE DO SIGN
WITH BUILT AND WE ARE
ECOLOGICALLY MAINTAIN THESE THE
GARDENS. LET ME TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT AND I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US A SON
NOR NOT ONLY A FAR COOPERATIVES
BECAUSE OF OUR CONCERN FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. I'M A CHANGED
SINCE OUR INCEPTION AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE HAVE ON THE SIGN ANY
INSTALLED ON HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE GARDENS A HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET OF GRASS
HAS BEEN REMOVED. THE GREAT
FATHER LANDED TO LET. US
SYSTEM. FOUR POINT I MILLION
GALLONS PER YEAR THINK ABOUT
THAT A LOAN AND IS THE ARE DRAW
AND MATURE. AND ALL OVER AND
OUR STATE. YOU HAVE TO OCT THE
ADDRESS TO CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
IT COMES TO ENVIRONMENTAL
REFUGEES FOR ALL OF WORLD.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FAMILIES IN
THE EARTH AND STUDENT OF BEING
ENGAGE AND OUR WORK. THAT WAS
VERY EXCITING AND DOT HERE IS
ONE OF THE GRAY WATER SYSTEMS
THAT WE'RE DOING THE
INSTALLATION WITH ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS AND THROUGH IT ALL I'M
GONNA TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR DO IT ON THE NEXT
SLIDE. BUT THERE'S IT BASICALLY
THESE OF FRUIT TREES ARE GOING
TO BE WATER FIVE FRUIT TREES BY
A GRAY WATER SYSTEM GRAY WATER
SYSTEM SO IT'S A REALLY GREAT
WAY TO GO A LAUNDRY TO
LANDSCAPE TO BE ABLE TO RE USE
THAT WATER. AND TO GROW A LOT
OF FOOD AND SO THIS IS ONE OF
THE WE ARE QUALIFIED ON
CERTIFIED. GRAY WATER
INSTALLERS FROM THE GRAY WATER
ACTION. AND WE GO THROUGH ALL
THE- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
CARE PLAN THEY CARE AND FAIR
SHARE WHEN IT COMES TO. DO THE
TO DO TO THIS WORK. SO I
THOUGHT ON ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
OF LET THE VIOLENCE AND
OPPRESSION OF HONDURAS AFTER
THE CREW THAT TODD BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE. OUR WITH TWO
CHILDREN AND HIS FAMILY I'M
THROUGH THE PHONE HIMSELF IN
SOME WAYS AND NOT ABLE TO. MAKE
ENDS MEET. AND STRUGGLING AND
SOME MANY TIMES ARE THROUGH TO
ACTUALLY WERE WAS CHEATED OFF
WORK THAT HAD BEEN THAT HE HAD
DONE HE'S A VERY SKILLED FOR
WORKER FAST LEARNER. AN AMAZING
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY I THINK
CALIFORNIA BENEFITS I MEAN ARE
THROUGH HERE BUT HE DOES GREAT
WORK. WORK ETHIC. AND ARE
REALLY IS. SOME TWO TWO BOB AS
A MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY.
HELLO GRATEFUL TO HAVE TRAINING
FROM MY YARD TO DO LAWN
LANDSCAPE THAN LOGICAL GARDENS.
AND SO YOU'RE NOT BEING ABLE TO
HAVE A PEACE OF MIND THE WHOLE
ACTUALLY SPEND TIME WITH YOUR
LONG WEEKENDS. AND ARE THE SAME
TO HAVE PEACE OF MIND UP UP
THAT HE GETS PAID THAT HE'S
WORK AND THAT. THAT HE AS A
PERSON HAS DIGNITY IS TREATED
WITH DIGNITY SO AND TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO BUILD COMMUNITY
AS ANOTHER. RESTORATION
CONSERVATION ALSO THROUGH THE
WAS ALSO AND CONTINUES TO BE
CONCERNED. ABOUT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL. IMPACTS AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO OUR PLANET.
SO THIS IS ONE OF THOSE. WE'D
TO WASTE INSTEAD. A MATERIAL TO
BOND BILLS THAT YOU. IS THE
LITTLE BOX YOU'RE WITH T. TOP
LIKE THAT. WE ARE. ABLE TO MAKE
IT FOR US CENTER PIECES FOR
EVENTS WEDDINGS AND WHAT NOT.
FROM FENCES THAT WE REMOVE A
REDWOOD. AND SO FRIENDS THIS
GOAL IS LOOKING AT THESE
LANDSCAPE THERE YOU SEE THE
BEFORE. BEEF BUT THEY'RE USED.
THE. INNER AND RIGHT BEHIND IT
BUNCH OF BREAK. IT'S YOU OUGHT
TO. BOB TO THE LOOK AND FEEL.
NO HE'S AND WE SHAUN OFFER THIS
TYPE OF. THERE ARE MORE BY
GOING IN MORE SUCH A ROCK THE
SIZE OF THE UNIT AND THAT THE
BENEFITS OF BEING. AN ENERGY
AND UNIT WE HAVE THESE BENEFITS.
THIS IS THE EXAMPLE OF THE GRAY
WATER SYSTEM LAUNDRY TO
LANDSCAPE YOU CAN SEE THE
PLUMBING THESE OF THEM A THREE
BOB GOOD TO THE FRUIT TREES.
AND TALL. THIS IS VERY EXCITING
WORK I WE CAN REMAIN MANY MORE
CALL UPS. OR FOR OTHER PAPERS
TO UP TO DO THIS WHAT AND THE
GROWING AMOUNT BECAUSE OF ALL
THE SAVINGS THAT WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT CLIMATE CHARLIE LUNGES
REQUIRED AND ECOLOGICAL
LANDSCAPING APPROACH AND WE
BUILD COMMUNITY AND TRAIN
WORKERS. AND ENGAGING NEIGHBORS.
AND FAMILIES WE INTRODUCE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLAN. OF
FLORA AND PHONE NOT TO THE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE AN
APPRECIATION. LIKE VERY VERY UP
SHOULD TIP OF YOUR SUPPORT AND
ALL OF YEAH FOR DOING BEFORE.
THANK YOU ELISABETH AND OUR-
FINAL PANELIST IS ROCK CITY
YELLOW WITH NURSES CAN
COOPERATIVE. OKAY STARTED ALL
DAY FIND IT MY NAME THREE CHRIS
ITALO I WORK IN RESEARCH AT
SEIU UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS
WERE A LABOR UNION OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOSPITAL
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
ALLIED HEALTH CARE WORKERS SO
FOLKS IN JOBS LAKE LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSING EVEY S. R.
JANET WORK DIETARY WORK. PEOPLE
AND ALSO. CAN PROVIDE
CLASSIFICATION IN HOSPITALS.
INCLUDED TODAY AND THAT THAT
HAPPENED THANK YOU. I WANTED TO
YOU TIMES CHANGE THINGS SAYS
THE PERSON YOU'RE FROM FROM
ORGANIZED LABOR I WANTED TO
SHARE WHAT I SEE AS THE NATURAL
ALIGNMENT BETWEEN. YOU KNOW
DEVELOPING WORKER COOPS AND
ALSO ORGANIZED LABOR. AND THEN
I ALSO WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
OUR EXPERIENCE AT U. H. W.
WORKING WITH A GROUP OF
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSES WHO
CREATED AND INCORPORATED A
WORKER COOP AND THEN UNIONIZED
WITH OUR UNION. SO THE SO THE
GUIDING PRINCIPLES OR I GUESS
BY YOU PROPOSITION KIND WORK
COOPER AND FAMILY UNIONS. IN MY
VIEW. LAUGHING. THAT WAS FIRST
LIGHT AND HAD THE SEVEN COOPER
SUPPORT BILLS THINGS LIKE
DEMOCRATIC MEMBER CONTROL ALL
NUMBER. INCOME INTO EDUCATION
TRAINING ARE ALL THINGS THAT.
WITH FIRST EMPOWER WORKERS AND
TO BUILD STABLE AND DURING A
CONNIE'S BUT ASIDE FROM THE
VALUES ALIGNMENT UNIONS AND
CAUGHT SHARE YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE OTHER COMMITMENTS THAT I'VE
THAT I'VE LISTED HERE SO THINGS
LIKE ACCESS TO MEANINGFUL
BENEFITS AND TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT GIVE PEOPLE. ACCESS TO
COPE CAREER MOBILITY. SO I
THINK ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
THE GROWING ECONOMY AND THAT
KIND OF CONSTANT RESTRUCTURING
OF WORK. LEAVE BECAUSE OF A
MISSION AND OTHER AN ALMOND
SAYS. AND THIS THINK THIS.
MISSION OF THIS EXPECT AN OF ON
DEMAND WORK IS ALSO. YOUR EARLY
TROUBLING. I GUESS THAT YOU CAN
CALL I'M SURE PERSPECTIVE I
THINK IT RECENTLY. GET
WORKFORCE MODELS THAT SHARE
EQUITY GAINS ACROSS THE WORK
FORCE. TO KIND OF FIGHT THAT
TIED OF TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
PEOPLE'S LABOR. AND SO WE SAW
THAT WE SAW WITH THE LVM WORKER
COOPS WHICH I'LL TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IN A MINUTE
THAT THERE'S ALSO REALLY
SERIOUS STRUCTURAL ADVANTAGES
OF MARRYING ARE PARTNERING
UNIONS THEN COLLAPSED TO GIVE
PEOPLE. ACCESS TO BENEFITS AND
PORTABILITY OF BENEFITS. AND
YOU KNOW BUT ALSO REAL WORK
PRETTY PLACE PROTECTIONS. THAT
ARE BEING A ROAD IN ALL KINDS
OF WAYS ELSEWHERE IN THE
ECONOMY. SO I THINK SOME PEOPLE
ARE KIND OF LIKE WHAT IS THE
HOW DOES A UNION COOP WORK SO
JUST VERY QUICKLY DESCRIBE THAT.
IT'S NOT REAL. UNION AND THEN
IT SORT OF EMPLOYER WOULD RACK.
BOB WORKERS. A SET OF WORKERS
FREEDOM GETTING DE THAT THEN SO
SHE SELECT A MAN I'M WHICH ONES
YOU KNOW AND YOU BE WHO WAS ON
THAT AGREEMENT SO THAT'S IT IN
THAT WAY I BELIEVE IT'S SIMILAR
THE MAJOR DIFFERENCE IS THE
VALUES ALIGNMENT THAT I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE SUCCESS OF
THE COOP IS BASICALLY
INHERENTLY TIED TO THE SUCCESS
OF THE UNION. AND OF COURSE
BECAUSE OF THE COOP STRUCTURE
INSTEAD OF THERE BEING LIKE AN
ADVERSARIAL SORT OF BOSS WORKER
DYNAMIC THERE IS AN
ACCOUNTABILITY LOOP AND THERE'S
A LIKE A BUILT IN CHECK ON
POWER THAT DISABLES A SUBSET.
OF PEOPLE FROM CAPITALIZING OFF
THE LABOR OF OTHERS. SO I'M A
TWENTY. TELL YOU ABOUT THE ALL
THE ENDS THAT WE'VE HAD THE
CHANCE TO WORK WITH. SO WHEN I
A WE. JUST XIN THIS IS THE LAST.
POINT THAT THIS IS NORMAL. ARE
AT A LOT OF IN ORDER COOPER
THROUGHOUT THE TREE IN AS YOU
ALL SORTS OF INTO THESE IN FACT
BRING CHILD CARE HOME CARE BOB
IN UP TO MY FEET. AND THEN ALL
I NOTED IN THE UP IN THE HAND
OUT. THAT WE- PUT TOGETHER FOR
THIS THEY HIGHLIGHTED THE
GREEN. TAXI WORKERS COOP WORK
WITH IN IN DENVER WITH C. WA.
ANYWAY LEAVE THAT BUT I SO I
JUST WANTED TO FINISH BY
TELLING YOU ABOUT THAT THE
AUDIENCE SO. THEY'RE A GROUP OF
LPNS WHO. IS LIGHT OKAY SHALL
NURSES. SO WE TRY TO TAKE
CONTROL BACK UP THEIR WORK.
HOUSE OF WATER IS. BEING PRIEST
FRIENDS AND REYES THANK HELP.
I'LL BE IN SCHOOL. SORT OF
SHIFTING OVER TIME I'LL BE AND
JOBS ARE BEING SHELLED
HOSPITALS AND CLINICS INTO LONG
TERM CARE AND SORT OF MORE
DIFFICULT KIND OF BURN OUT
SETTINGS SO THIS GROUP OF THEY
WERE ALL WOMEN SO THIS GROUP OF
WOMEN. DECIDED THAT THEY WANTED
TO CREATE A CO OP WHERE THEY
COULD DO VISITS IN PEOPLE'S
HOMES IN CALIFORNIA WHITE LPNS
CAN BE LICENSE CAN BE SUPRISED
REMOTELY BY A PHYSICIAN. AT
WHICH IS A MEANINGFUL THING FOR
THEIR BUSINESS MODEL BECAUSE
WHEN THEY VISIT SOME A PATIENT
IN THE HOME THAT CREATES A-
BILLABLE CLINICAL ENCOUNTER. SO
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
THEIR THEIR MODEL IS BASED ON
AND THEY THEY SPECIFICALLY
WANTED TO BE REACHING. LOW
INCOME COMMUTE COMMUNITIES SOME
PATIENTS WHO ARE FACING
TRANSPORTATION AND CHILD CARE
AND OTHER SORTS OF BARRIERS TO
SEEKING CARE OR ACTUALLY
GETTING CARE IN CLINICS. SO THE
ALL THE ENDS THEY FORMED A CO
OP THEY HIRED PROFESSIONAL
MANAGERS. THROUGHOUT COOP
DEVELOPMENT FROM CALL THE GUY
CA GROUP. THAT HELPS TO KIND OF
TRAINING AND EDUCATION AND
MANAGEMENT. AND THEN THE
UNIONIZED WITH THE UNION A
SUBSET OF THEM CREATED A
BARGAINING COMMITTEE AND THEY
BARGAINED WITH THE UNION. AND I
AND I GOT TO BE A PART OF THAT
FROM THE UNION SIDE WHICH WAS
REALLY WONDERFUL. AND THEN THEY
GOT THEIR FIRST SET OF WORK
WHICH WAS. THEY GOT A THEY DID
A PILOT PROJECT PROJECT WITH
SOME FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CLINIC IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES
CALLED ST JOHN'S WELL CHILD.
AND THEY DID A SET OF THREE
HUNDRED VISITS TO PREGNANT
WOMEN WHO RUN MEDIC HAL THROUGH
A PROGRAM CALLED CPS P.
COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL
SERVICES PROGRAM. WHICH IS SORT
OF LIKE A SET OF VISITS FOR
THIS PARTICULAR POPULATION AND
SO LIKE LACTATION SUPPORT AND
PSYCHOSOCIAL SUPPORT ALL SORTS
OF THINGS THAT PEONS ARE.
PERFECTLY TRAINED TO DO AND SO
I HAVE A HANDOUT THAT I'M GONNA
LEAVE HERE FOR FOLKS ABOUT THAT
FROM THE FROM THE COOP BUT BY
BASICALLY EVERY KIND OF METRIC
YOU COULD MEASURE IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE SHOWING UP FOR VISITS
AND HOW PEOPLE FELT ABOUT THE
VISITS AND THE REVENUE
GENERATED FOR THE CLINIC. THE
PILOT WAS A GREAT SUCCESS. THE
TWENTY TWO. LPNS WHO WERE
EMPLOYEES OF THE COP. WHO ARE
THERE ACTUALLY ALL BILINGUAL.
AND THEY'RE ALL FROM THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE- PATIENTS
WERE SERVED. THEY ALSO HAVE.
REALLY WONDERFUL THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCE SO I
GUESS I'LL LEAVE IT THERE.
THANK YOU RARE REALLY
APPRECIATED HIS SOMEONE WHO'S
AUTHORED AND CO AUTHORED NUMBER
OF BILLS REGARDING HOME CARE
WORKERS AND WHAT HAVE YOU. YOU
KNOW THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THE
AND IN FACT. THAT POPULATION
TENDS TO BE MORE MAJORITY WOMEN
MANY FROM THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY TO LOOK AT
LANDSCAPING RESTAURANT WORKERS
USING IT A COMMON THREAD. OF UP
ANY COMMITTEES WHO DON'T OFTEN
ARE OFTEN EMPOWERED THAT AGAIN
EMPOWERMENT TO THIS COOPERATIVE
STRUCTURE WHICH I WHICH I
REALLY LIKE TO SEE MORE OF AND
SO THAT'S PART OF THESE ALREADY
IN THIS HERE TODAY. BEFORE
FURTHER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
UP HERE I LIKE INNER DO USE
BETTY YOUNG WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
OFFICE LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT THANK HER FOR BEING
HERE. THIS MORNING ABOUT
ANYTHING AROUND. SO I THINK
THINK BODY FOR THE WORK THAT
SHE'S DOING ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS HERE IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND THE SUPPORT OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THAT
WORK AND I. HAVE A COUPLE OF
AND ONE THING SUE YOU HAD
MENTIONED BY THE WAY I'VE BEEN
TO THE LAKE SHORE BAKERY ON A
NUMBER OF OCCASIONS AND HAVE.
AND APPRECIATED. AND IS THE
IDEA THAT THESE ARE STILL
BUSINESSES LADIES ARE. I
SOMETIMES PUTTING COOPERATIVES
LIKE IT'S A COMMUNE OR
SOMETHING. AND I KNOW THESE ARE
ACTUAL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE TO
RUN A PROFIT AT THE MAKE. MAKE
THEIR PAYROLL. AND IDEALLY HAVE
A HAVE A PROFIT AND IDEA I
THINK IS SAID. THAT ITS IT'S
BOTH THE PROCEDURES AS WELL AS
THE WEALTH IS SHARED AMONGST
THOSE DOING THE WORK. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
MENTIONED BUT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PROCESS YOU
WENT THROUGH. IS THE DIFFICULTY
GETTING FINANCING. THAT YOU
WENT TO TRADITIONAL BANKS AND
CAN GET FINANCING. AND I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN CONVERSATIONS
INCLUDING AT THE STATE LEVEL
THAT THAT BUT YOU KNOW THE TWO
OF US WAS PART OF IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC BANKS. BUT EVEN BEYOND
THAT LIKE HOW DO WE GET BEYOND
THAT FINANCING HURDLE IN THE
PRIOR PANEL TO TALK ABOUT WAYS
A STAKE IN THE HELP. BUT IS
THAT THE BIGGEST ISSUE THAT YOU
SEEN IN TERMS OF CREATING
COOPER IS ARE THERE OTHER
ISSUES THAT. ARE ON EQUAL
FOOTING. WELL I THINK. I THINK
IT COMES DOWN TO MONEY I THINK
IT DOES DEFINITELY COME DOWN TO
MONEY BECAUSE I MEAN IT
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE GOING TO.
START A BUSINESS YOU'RE YOU
NEED THAT CAPITAL RIGHT. AND
NORMALLY WERE TALKING ABOUT
WORKERS THE DON'T HAVE. YOU
KNOW THAT AMOUNT OF CAPITAL TO
PUT INTO A BUSINESS. WELL WE
STARTED PEOPLE WERE BUYING AND
IT FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH
AND NOW IT. IF THE BUSINESSES
ARE SUCCESSFUL I'M PAID BACK
THEIR BANK LOANS IS DOWN TO ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH. SO
NORMALLY SOME IS COMING TO THE
BUSINESS AS HILLARY SAID AND
THEY'RE JUST TAKING THAT. AND
PAYROLL DEDUCTIONS SO YOU NEED
THE CAPITAL TO START. THIS
THAT'S THE- MAIN THING AND
SINCE IT'S A COOPERATIVE I
THINK IT'S HARDER. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT THE NORM
UNITED STATES SOMETHING THAT'S
HARDER TO GET. FINANCE THE
OTHER CHALLENGES WOULD BE JUST
CHALLENGES OF COMPROMISING
COMMUNICATION. AND THE NORMAL
JUST KIND OF LET'S GET THIS UP
AND RUNNING. BUT I. THINK THAT
IF THE FINANCES WERE THERE WHEN
PEOPLE APPROACH US SOME PEOPLE
APPROACH IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
CREATE. YOU KNOW EIGHT.
COOPERATIVES IN THE BAY AREA
THAT ARE DOING VERY WELL. AND
THEY APPROACH US AND THEY'RE
LIKE OH WE WANTED THERE'S A
MANDY AND YOU KNOW. UP IN
ARCADIA. AND I WAS LIKE OH WELL
IF YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS YOU'RE GONNA NEED
LIKE HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THEN WHO WERE IT WERE YOU
GOING TO GET. YOU KNOW WHO'S
GOING TO SIGN OFF ON THAT. SO
YOU KNOW IT'S A REAL CONUNDRUM
TO ME ESPECIALLY SINCE WE-
WERE. WE INITIALLY GOT. A LOT
OF SUPPORT WITHIN THE
COOPERATIVE COMMUNITY THROUGH
THE CHEESE BOARD. SO IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THE THERE'S AN- THINK
THE THINGS ARE NOT IN PLACE
OUTSIDE OF THESE FANTASTIC
PEOPLE THAT WERE PART OF OUR
FIRST PANEL THERE HELPING PUSH
THIS AGENDA. THERE'S NOT STUFF
IN PLACE LIKE FOR THREE FOLKS
TAKE THREE PEOPLE MEDICAL UP
CODE THE SB SPDC AT CITY HALL.
IT'S LIKE OKAY AND NOW WHAT. I
MEAN SO I THINK IT'S JUST. I
THINK. IT GET GOES BACK TO
EDUCATION PS FROM THE EARLIER
PANEL LET'S TALK ABOUT AS WELL.
AND THANK YOU OF AN ELIZABETH
ONE OF THE- OPEN TO TALKING
ABOUT. SMART YARDS AND YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE ISSUES IN A AND
ESPECIALLY AS SOMEONE THAT
CERTAINLY AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES AS WELL FINDING WAYS
TO MOVE INTO THE GREEN ECONOMY.
MOVE AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS.
BUT DO IT IN A WAY THAT A PLUS
WORKERS AND THAT'S A OFTENTIMES
PART OF THE CHALLENGE I MEAN
LOOKED AT THE REALITY IS THAT A
LOT OF THE POSSIBLE JOBS ARE
REALLY GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS
THAT PEOPLE ARE SENDING THEIR
KIDS TO COLLEGE. OTHER OF
BUYING HOMES AND THEY'RE LIVING
THE AMERICAN DREAM AND YET A
LOT OF THE JOBS THAT COMING IN
THE GREEN SECTOR DON'T MATCH UP
IN TERMS OF THAT EMPOWERMENT
THE WORKER. AND SO YOU KNOW THE
THAT'S ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE
YOU KNOW I OFTENTIMES TALK
ABOUT ABOUT WHETHER SOLAR
INSTALLATION OR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IN TERMS OF THE SMART
YARDS. OF EMPOWERING WORKERS
AND IN THIS KIND OF THE NEW
GREEN DEAL KIND OF SENTIMENT.
OF ENSURING THAT WE'RE
EMPOWERING WORKERS AS WE MOVE
IN THAT GREEN DIRECTION. AND SO
I KNOW THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU OFTENTIMES BRING UP
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE WHAT HAVE YOU. AND SO
THE WHAT IT WELL THEY ARE NOT
FIVE COMMENT ON THAT ASPECT OF
IT OF MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
CREATING GOOD JOBS TO REPLACE.
THE QUALITY JOBS EVEN IF IT'S
IN THE BOSTON THE. QUALITY JOSH
OF THOSE DOING THE WORK. IN
THAT TRANSITION. ABSOLUTELY SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP THE
GREAT NEW GREAT DEAL. I WAS A
LITTLE BIT KINDA HELD BLOCK
COME FROM MOM MENTIONING THAT.
BUT WE ARE REALLY DOING THAT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH THIS ITEM
SMALL VERY SMALL SCALE. AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR. A
FEDERAL MANDATE OR- YOU KNOW TO
BE SIGNED WE CAN DO A LOT
THERE'S A LOT TO DO. AND I HAVE
TO SAY THAT THE THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE. THE COMMUNITY. NOT JUST
IN FRONT THE SAN JOSE ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA. REALLY ARE READY
FOR THAT. THEY ARE READY TO
TRANSITION. TO MAKE THAT
TRANSITION TO STAR. WE LIKE I
SAID I MEAN. THIS MORE YARDS IS
A VERY. SMALL EXAMPLE OF HOW WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT. THE THESE
TYPE OF WORK ARE REQUIRES A LOT
OF SKILL. IT'S NOT JUST YOU
KNOW LIKE OKAY WE TAKE OUR
PEACE SO LONG ACROSS AND. AND
DO THAT I MEAN IT'S SKILLS LIKE
UGH. IRRIGATION SYSTEMS ARE OUT
WHICH IS A LOT OF TRAINING
DOING THE I MEAN FOR A GRAY ONE
AND SYSTEMS PLANTING FRUIT
TREES THERE IS A HUGE. DEMAND
FOR LIKE PEOPLE WANT TO REALLY
GROW THEIR OWN FOOD AND THE
YARDS THERE'S A LOT OF WORK OUT
THERE WE CAN START DOING IT AND
YOU NAME IT YOU WE CAN CREATE.
LIKE EVEN THAT MAKING THE MODEL
IS WITH ORGANIC. YOU KNOW
INGREDIENTS WE CAN CREATE AND
IN FACT MY I ASK MY I ASK IS TO
CREATE A CENTER FOR
COOPERATIVES HERE IN SAN JOSE
AND WE COULD DO THAT AND START
HAVING THOUGHT EDUCATION WE
NEED A BUILDING. I MEAN IF
GOOGLE CAN GET SOME KIND OF
SUPPORT BY THE. CITY O'DONNELL
SAID TO HAVE YOU KNOW. HI TECH
WORK IT WE COULD CREATE A
CENTER FOR COOPER DOESN'T
ALMOST A WHERE WE CAN MAKE
THINGS. I MEAN ALSO THERE IS
ANOTHER VERY INTERESTING THING
THAT KIDS CAN BE ARE AS THE ARE
VERY INTERESTED IN INSTEAD OF
SPENDING AND PARENTS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT SPENDING A
LOT OF SCREEN TIME THEY CAN
ACTUALLY BE LEARNING AND WE
HAVE THOSE WORKSHOPS. WITH OUR
YOUNG GIRLS LEARNING HOW TO USE
POWER TOOLS HOW TO MAKE THINGS
WITH THEIR HANDS THERE IS A
HUGE BENEFIT. IN THAT ITSELF IN
TERMS OF OUR OUR WELL BEING AND
A PSYCHOLOGICALLY MENTALLY.
PHYSICALLY TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO MAKE THINGS WE NEED TO GET
BACK TO THAT. AND I THINK OUR
PEOPLE ARE READY IT WOULD JUST
THEY JUST NEED PEOPLE SOMEONE
TO ACTUALLY. ANSWER THE
QUESTION ON HOW AND WHY AND YOU
KNOW HERE IT IS THE
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDE THAT SO.
THIS BILL THAT CLUB UNDER HERE
SOME OF THE OKAY. A SUMMER
RIVAS. AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION AND-
YOU KNOW IT'S A BASED ON THE
TESTIMONY AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES OBVIOUSLY THE
FINANCING AND THIS INFORMATION
GAP OF THE EDUCATION WHAT WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE MOST IMMEDIATE
STEPS THAT THIS THE YOU KNOW
THE STATE LEGISLATURE CAN DO.
TO SUPPORT YOU KNOW THE
CREATION OF THESE CO OPS. I'LL
TAKE A SHOT AT THAT THE FIRST
THING AND I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
IN THE FIRST PANEL IS AROUND
THE EDUCATION. AND AWARENESS.
THAT THESE MODELS EXIST AND
THAT THEY'RE NOT FRIENDS AND
THEY'RE NOT THESE THESE THINGS
THAT ARE ARE JUST. YOU KNOW
MIRED IN ONE AREA OR ANOTHER
THEY THEY THEY ACROSS SPECTRUMS
ARE MANUFACTURING THE RETAIL
THEIR SKILLED LABOR THERE
SERVICE ORIENTED THEIR RETAIL
BASE THERE ALL ALL OF THOSE.
AND I JUST WANT TO BE JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING AND I WENT
THROUGH IN IN OUR BUSINESS.
WHEN WE FIRST OPENED UP WE GAVE
WE TRY TO BRING CORPORATE STUFF
THAT WAS WE REALLY LIKED
WITHOUT ALL THE OVERHEAD AND
LAYERS THAT WE DIDN'T LIKE. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DID IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT IS WE GIVE WE
GIVE BONUSES TO ARE WE GET
EVALUATIONS OF OUR WORK FORCE
AND GIVE BONUSES. AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH IT WAS ALMOST
HALF OF THE TEAM THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT A BONUS WAS. THEY DID
NOT HAVE NEVER HAD A BONUS THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS WHY YOU
GIVING ME THIS MONEY I YOU KNOW
I APPRECIATE IT BUT WHY YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT IS THAT WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN. AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT AS YOUR
BASELINE OF POTENTIAL BASELINE
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GONE NOW
GOING TO BE TALENTS WITH
BUSINESS OPERATIONS GOVERNANCE
READER PNL OR BALANCE SHEET.
THERE IS A LARGE GAP OF BASE
KNOWLEDGE THAT NEEDS TO BE
BROUGHT IN AND HOW DO YOU GET
THAT EDUCATION. PUSHED INTO A
WORKFORCE THAT IS WORKING
SOMETIMES THIRTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE FIFTY FIVE HOURS A WEEK
THEY HAVE FAMILY THAT THEY'RE
RAISING THEIR ON MAYBE. TWO
JOBS. AND HOW DO YOU INTEGRATE
THAT INTO A PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS
THE WORK FORCE TO GET THAT
EDUCATION AND NOT JUST TO
CONVERT PEOPLE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE CONVERTING TO GET THE BASE
KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY'RE
SUCCESSFUL THAT'S WHAT. PROJECT
WOULD HELP US DO IS WITH ONE ON
ONE TRAINING IS WITH OUR TEAM
AND WE ACTUALLY STILL RETAIN
THE SERVICES OF PROJECT WOULD
BE BECAUSE THEY'RE HELPING DO
THAT KIND OF ONE ON ONE
TRAINING. WITH OUR TEAM
INTERNALLY TO BUILD UP OUR OWN
BENCH STRENGTH. WE CAN. YEAH I
THINK THE TO THAT CONTENT TO
GIVE WORKERS NEW ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE WORKING IN A RESTAURANT
OR OTHER TYPE OF BUSINESS AND
ARE TOLD BY THE OWNER OF ONE OF
YOUR TIRING SENATE EVEN KNEW
THAT THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM TO ASK CONTINUE AND IT
SHOULD BE MORE POWER TO THE
WORK THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN DOING
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES YOU KNOW
IT'S SOME OF THE RESTAURANTS
JOB YOU WILL HAVE WORKERS I'VE
BEEN THERE FOR FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN YEARS AND- THEY- KNOW THE
BUSINESS JUST AS WELL AS THE
OWNERSHIP DOES. YET THEY DON'T
KNOW THAT OPPORTUNITY EXISTS
AND SOUGHT. TO BE HEARD FROM
MULTIPLE FOLKS THAT THE
EDUCATION PIECE. AND FORMING
SMALL BUSINESS. SPD SEASON
THOSE ARE ADVISING. SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT IS EVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY AT THAT THE THAT
THE CITIES. COUNTIES CAN ALSO
BE PART OF THAT EDUCATION
PROCESS. CAN I OUR POINT OUT A
LOT SO WE IT'S MY ARTS ARE COOL
UP ALSO STARTED THE BECAUSE ONE
OF THE PRINCIPLES OF
COOPERATIVES THAT'S EDUCATION.
AND TRAINING A RICH AND WE
STARTED A NONPROFIT SOME
MEMBERS OF THAT BORE ARE HERE
AND THE NONPROFIT ON THROUGH
THE NONPROFITS HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET GROUNDS ON FUNDING BECAUSE
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES AS YOU WE
ALL KNOW HERE. AS FUNDING I WE
START WITH MY OURS WAS THE
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS AND I
HUNDRED DOLLARS DROP SOME USE
TOOLS AND TO THIS DAY WERE
WORKING OUT WITH SHOE STRINGS
BASICALLY BECAUSE OF THAT
FUNDING OPPORTUNITY THAT LONG
AND YOU KNOW HOW DO WE GET.
HOPEFULLY WITH PUBLIC BANKING
IT WILL BE GREAT RIGHT SO WE
CAN MAYBE WORK AND- TO GETTING
LONGS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BUT HOW DO YOU GET ALONG AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO PAY AND
WORKERS WE DON'T WANT TO BE ON
THE HOOK FOR THAT. SO IT WILL
BE GREAT TO ACTUALLY HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GET SOME KIND OF.
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES TO START
UP. COSTS AND WE'RE STILL KIND
OF DEALING WITH THAT.
APPRECIATE THAT AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO SEE THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT I DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE
BUT WE DO HAVE COUNCILMEMBER
MARGARET A CLASSICAL WITH US.
HERE WHO'S ALSO BEEN A CHAMPION
IN REPRESENTING A DISTRICT FIVE
YOU SAN JOSE HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR WORKERS AND
CERTAINLY UP LOOKING. AS
SOMEONE WHO ALSO LOOKS FOR
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO CREATE
SUSTAINABLE AND IS TO IS A
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY. SO NOW UP
PUBLIC COMMENT. WHAT IT WILL DO
THAT FOR A FEW MINUTES. HI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA MY NAME
IS QUÉ AND PANEL MY NAME IS
CHAMELEON IS WHEN THE KNEE AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
SOMEONE'S MAYFAIR. I WANTED TO
SUPPORT WHAT I HEARD BY A LOT
OF YOUR PANELISTS TODAY IN
TERMS OF GOVERNMENT SUPPORT FOR
HELPING TO INCUBATE COOPS AND
GET EDUCATION OUT INTO
COMMUNITY. TWO YEARS AGO WE
FOUND OURSELVES AS A NON PROFIT
IN THE MIDST OF HELPING TO
INCUBATE A WORKER OWNER
COOPERATIVE FOR THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY I KNOW THAT WAS A
QUESTION. PRIMARILY MONOLINGUAL
SPANISH SPEAKING WITH MAKE
STATUS HOUSEHOLDS. I'M WE FOUND
OURSELVES THERE BECAUSE OF A
NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY BUT NOT
BECAUSE WE KNEW HOW TO DO IT SO
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
PANELISTS BECAUSE I THINK
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE PANELISTS
ORGANIZATION. HELPED US IN THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS AND THE
CAPACITY BUILDING WE NEED TO
HELP GET THIS CALL UP OFF THE
GROUND. THAT IS LIKE THAT ONE
OF THE NUMBER ONE PHILOSOPHIES
OF COOPS IN TERMS OF WORKING
AGAINST. COMPETITION BUT RATHER
COOPERATION AND SO THAT WAS
REALLY HELPFUL. BUT I THINK IT
TWO YEARS IN NOW SOME OF OUR
LEARNINGS THAT I WANTED TO HOLD
UP FOR ALL OF YOU IS THAT. THE
AMOUNT OF TIME IN
INTENTIONALITY ESPECIALLY WITH
WORKING WITH SOME OF OUR MOST
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES TO GET
THEM TO. HAVING A PROFITABLE
BUSINESS IS VERY INTENSIVE. OF
THE AMOUNT OF LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT AND SUPPORT AT THE
AMOUNT OF CAPITAL INVESTMENT
THAT'S REQUIRED ON THE FRONT
END. WHEN WE STARTED THIS
PROCESS WE DIDN'T KNOW ALL OF
THAT WAS GOING TO BE REQUIRED.
SO SIMILAR TO WHAT ELIZABETH
SAID YOU KNOW WE USED OUR
NONPROFIT STRUCTURE TO SECURE
PRIVATE FUNDING TO THEN.
REINVEST IT RIGHT BACK INTO THE
INCUBATION OF A COOPERATIVE. I
DON'T THINK THAT'S THE MOST
SUSTAINABLE MODEL. IT ACTUALLY
THEN PERPETUATES COMPETITION
AMONGST NON PROFITS AS WELL. SO
I THINK ANY WHERE YOU CAN HAVE
MORE PUBLIC FUNDS I'M INVESTING
DIRECTLY INTO THESE KINDS OF
BUSINESSES THE BETTER. AND THEN
I WOULD ADD THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT SB DC'S OR
OTHER PEOPLE WHO CAN INVEST
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. MAKING
SURE THAT IT'S NOT ONLY ON THE
BUSINESS FUNDAMENTALS. BUT ALSO
SUPPORTING THE SOFT SKILLS OF
COOPERATION NEGOTIATION.
CONFLICT RESOLUTION BECAUSE I
THINK WE HAVE SOME OF THE
WORKERS HERE TODAY I MEAN I
THINK THOSE HAVE BEEN THE
HARDEST CONVERSATIONS. AND SO
WHEN YOU ARE COMING FROM A
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND EQUITY
FRAME. AND YOU'RE WANTING TO
BUILD COMMUNITY WHEN YOU
TRANSITION INTO THIS PLACE OF
BUSINESS SOME OF THE-
CAPITALISTIC TENANTS JUST.
NEVER REAR THEIR UGLY HEAD BACK
INTO THE SYSTEM SO LIKE A TON
OF LEARNING. THAT WE'VE HAD IN
THIS PAST YEAR BUT I'M I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THAT HAVING THAT. OUR
STATION I. HUNDRED SUPPORT
BETH. YEAH A. I AM NO WELL GOES
FROM A MINIMUM BREWING CO OP
I'M ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
WE'RE NOT WORKER COOP THAT I'M
HERE BECAUSE WE LIKE TO OFFER.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORTER ONE.
WHEN I WAS A DEMOCRATICALLY RUN
BUSINESS WHERE MEMBERS DO
EVERYTHING FROM DESIGN YOUR
RECIPES TOASTING FUND BEER
RELATED EVENTS THE SELLING AND
MARKING THE BEER WE'RE ON MEET
UP SO YOU CAN SEE WHAT WE DO
THERE. WE CURRENTLY CONTRACT
BROUGH HER TIES IN SAN JOSE NOT
THAT FAR FROM HERE IN EAST CLIP
BRING IN SANTA CRUZ. WE DON'T
HAVE A PHYSICAL LOCATION. YET
SINCE RENTS ARE SO HIGH. WERE
BASED OUT OF SAN JOSE BUT WE
HAVE MEMBERS FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS LIFETIME
MEMBERSHIP FEE YOU MUST BE
TWENTY ONE TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK MOST TO
YOU HERE CAN CALL FIRE TO JOIN
US. SO. YEAH. YEAH ON ALSO
PERSONALLY I I'VE HIGHER DOES
THIS COMPANY FOR MY YARD AND
IT'S AWESOME OKAY ANYWAY SO OUR
MEMBERSHIP ALLOWS PARTICIPATION
AT ALL AND THE NUMBER OF EVENTS
AND CLEAN MONTHLY TASTING OF
OUR BEER ABILITY TO BUY A PAIR
OF ALSO PRICES IN TO BECOME
PART OF BAY AREA BE OUR
COMMUNITY AND EACH MEMBER
DECIDES HOW AND HOW MUCH THEY
LIKE TO BE INVOLVED. SO THAT'S
ABOUT IT SO IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED I'LL TALK TO YOU
LATER. THANK YOU FOR THAT YES
OUR OUR BEERS IN SEVERAL LOCAL
RESTAURANTS SOON AND BARS AND
AS WELL AS STORES THEM ANYWAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
BRIEF COMMERCIAL ARM AS- AS A
MEMBER AS A MEMBER OF THE STATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CRAFT
BREWING ALLOW IT. AND
COUNCILMEMBER CARRASCO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
ARE THERE WITH YOU I JUST YOU
KNOW YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT THERE HAS BEEN ASK
OF MORE COOPERATION NOT JUST
FROM THE CITY BUT FROM THE CITY
THE STATE LEVEL TO SUPPORT
COOPERATIVES WELL AND IN THIS
ISN'T AN THIS ISN'T A NEW
CONCEPT BUT IT'S OBVIOUSLY A
GROWING CONCEPT AND BECAUSE
THAT THERE'S A GROWING NEED AND
I YOU KNOW I KEEP SAYING THAT
OUR OUR OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
SOCIETIES ARE BECOMING MORE AND
MORE COMPLEX. OUR ISSUES ARE
BECOMING VERY COMPLEX AND NOW
SO ANYTHING THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
TOOLBOX I THINK IS GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE IT AND I
WANT TO THANK OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR ALWAYS HAVING HIS
FINGER ON THE PULSE OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE GET INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
IN OUR TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SUSTAINABLE BUT MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE WELL EDUCATED AND
THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO. TO HIM
BUT TO OTHERS THAT ARE EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD THERE'S AS YOU
HEAR THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT ARE. ARE ARE DOING A LOT
OF REALLY WONDERFUL WORK. THERE
ARE MAKING SURE THAT OUR
RESIDENTS ARE VERY WELL
INFORMED AND ARE WELL
REPRESENTED. OP I'M ALWAYS
MARVELED AT THE AT THE NATURE
AND THE MAKE UP OF THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE I REPRESENT THE EAST
SIDE OF SAN JOSE. CAMILLE WHO
YOU JUST HEARD US SPEAK UP IS A
WONDERFUL LEADER IN IN MY
DISTRICT AND I LOVE THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT. AND
I LOVE IT BECAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGES AND THE PERSEVERANCE
OF OUR OF OUR RESIDENTS THERE'S
NO OTHER DISTRICT THAT I WOULD
RATHER REPRESENT. IN THE EAST
SIDE OF SAN JOSE THE PROBLEM IS
THE POSSIBILITY AND THE
POTENTIAL OF THE EAST SIDE. IS.
REALLY UNBELIEVABLE AND SO TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE THESE KIND OF
CONVERSATION IS REALLY WHAT
ALLOWS US TO. HELP OUR
RESIDENTS FLOURISH AND BLOSSOM
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK
THAT FOR ME I WAS IN HERE FOR
THE FOR THE FULL CONVERSATION
OBVIOUSLY. BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT'S ABOUT HOW DO WE
ARE ASSISTING IT HOW DO WE FIND
IT HOW DO WE HAVE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL. AND HOW DO WE AT THE
END OF THE DAY FOR THIS AREA
FINE FACILITIES AND COMPETE IN
A VERY. COMPETITIVE REAL ESTATE
MARKET SO THAT'S GOING TO BE A
HUGE QUESTION MARK OVER
EVERYBODY'S HEAD SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS OBVIOUSLY. BUT
IT'S JUST VERY IRONIC THAT I
JUST LEFT A MEETING WITH A
BUSINESS OWNER. WHO SAID HOW DO
WE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL OF
ROCK THAT IS A- VERY IMPORTANT
CORRIDOR IN MY DISTRICT.
BECOMING VERY ACTIVATE IT SO
THAT ALL THE BUSINESSES DON'T
GET SQUEEZED OUT AND HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ENJOY THE
PROSPERITY THAT'S COMING INTO
THE EAST SIDE OF SAN JOSE. WHAT
A TIMELY CONVERSATION SO MORE
TO COME AND I KNOW THAT A LOT
OF FOLKS HERE WILL BE PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE OF
COURSE THE PANELISTS FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO BE HERE THANK YOU
COUNCIL MEMBER US. ALSO. MEMBER
BECAUSE- THOSE WERE THE BEST OF
ALL. THANK YOU FOR BEING THE
COUNCIL MEMBER AT LEAST TWO
YEARS WHILE WE WERE UP THERE ON
THE EIGHTEENTH FLOOR BUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'RE DOING AT THE STATE
LEVEL. OF COURSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I KNOW THAT YOU SHAKING
THINGS UP FOR A THE ENTIRE
STATE AND OF COURSE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIS FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. AND MISTER
PIKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CONGRESS
MEMBER WILL KIND OF WHO'S BEEN
A VERY PUBLIC SUPPORTER OF
WORKERS OPERATIVES. YEAH HI IF
THIS IS A GREAT SESSION THANKS
FOR. OSSIAN EVERYONE FOR
PUTTING THAT TOGETHER I DID
WANT TO JUST KIND OF GIVE A
QUICK UPDATE AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE MAIN STREET.
EMPLOYEE OWNERSHIP ACT WAS
PASSED ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
WHEN IT A LOT SO THAT'S A GOOD
START. AND CONGRESSMAN KANA IS
NOW WORKING WITH ACTUALLY
RICARDO'S GROUP THE U. S.
FEDERATION OF WORKER
COOPERATIVES AND A FEW OTHERS.
TO COME UP WITH SOME OF FOLLOW
UP BILL THAT WILL COVER SOME
ISSUES THAT WILL HELP.
FACILITATE THAT PREVIOUS BILL
INCLUDING. ONE BIG THING WOULD
BE TO ATTEMPT TO ELIMINATE
CAPITAL GAIN TAXES. FOR ANY
BUSINESS OWNER CELLS TO
EMPLOYEES IN ORDER TO
TRANSITION. SO THAT WOULD BE
ONE ELEMENT AS WELL AS GRANTS
AND EDUCATION AND RESOURCE
OPPORTUNITIES. IS ZAND THE
PANELIST IN THE PREVIOUS PANEL
POINTED OUT REGARDING MIAMI IF
A COMMUNITY IS NOT USED TO IT
YOU REALLY NEED TO MAKE THE
BUSINESS PITCH ON THE BUSINESS
SENSE. AND CLEARLY IN CONGRESS
CERTAINLY THE WAY IT'S
CURRENTLY COMPROMISED K. SET
UP. YOU'VE GOT A YOU GOTTA MAKE
SOME PITCHES THAT ARE GONNA HIT
THE BIPARTISAN CELL AND I THINK
THAT THE BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR A WORKER COOPS REALLY THERE
IS A THERE IS AN ARGUMENT RIGHT
NOW ESPECIALLY THE SILVER
TSUNAMI THE- SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE OWNED BY BABY BOOMERS
THAT ARE TRYING TO TRANSITION.
AND THEN SHOWING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A WORKERS TO GO
FROM SWEAT EQUITY TO BUSINESS
EQUITY. AND SO I THINK THERE IS
A REALLY SOLID BUSINESS
ARGUMENT THAT CAN BE MADE ON
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WILL BE
LOOKING TO DO THAT. DO OUR PART
I KNOW THE STATE AND THE COUNTY
THE CITIES ARE DOING THERE'S
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
PASSING THESE LAWS THEY CAN
HELP FIRST WITH THE CONVERSIONS
AND THEN ALSO BASICALLY LETTING
PEOPLE SEE HOW COWORKER ACOSTA
WORK. AND SO THEN WE CAN YOU
KNOW IS SUPPORT START UPS AS
WELL WHICH IS ANOTHER ELEMENT
SO THANKS VERY MUCH WE'RE
WORKING AT OUR. LEVEL AND I
KNOW EVERYONE ELSE'S TOO SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TOM. SO AS WE APPROACH NEWNESS
IN REVERSE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
NO I JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION TO BE AT MY FRIEND
AND MY COLLEAGUES A MEMBER
KALRA WHO'S NOT ONLY LEADER AND
IN THIS AREA BUT CERTAINLY. A
LEADER SO MANY AREAS A POINT TO
SAY CALIFORNIA BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY BEING HERE
AND I APPRECIATE BOTH OF THE
PANELS EVEN THOSE LATE FOR THE
FIRST PANEL I HAVE A DAUGHTER
WAS DOING HALF YEARS OLD IN
THIS OFFICE WE BACK IN
SACRAMENTO. AND SO I'VE TO IN
MY WITH MY DAY AND LOCKWOOD IF
I DON'T KNOW. A LOT WHAT IS IT
WHEN YOU LOOK ON YOUR PHONE IS
VERY VERY FAR FROM HERE. I WILL
BE AYE AYE I WILL BE HOME UNTIL
ABOUT. TEN OR ELEVEN. SO I HAD
TO SPEND SOMETIME MY DAUGHTER
THIS. IS A BUT IT'S GREAT TO BE
HERE AND THANK YOU OFFER
INFORMATION WAS. GREAT SO
MAKING. THEY MEDIA WORKING
COOPERATIVE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ANYWAY WHAT I DO WANT TO THANK.
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS REALLY FOR
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY AND
COMMENTARY. A DEFINITELY
HELPFUL TO ME AND TO
LEGISLATURE'S I INDICATED THIS
IS ALL. BEING LIVE STREAMED IN
ARCHIVES SO THAT THEY WILL
BENEFIT OUR ENTIRE LEGISLATURE
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THE STAFF
THAT. WORKS ON A LOT OF THAT ON
THE LOT OF THE BILLS. AND WILL
CERTAINLY CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION WILL BE HAVING A AND
ONE THING I. YOU KNOW WHAT ONE
OF THE LAST THINGS I DID WHEN I
WAS AT IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT THE LAST YEAR I WAS ON PTA
BOARD. THEM A LOT THE I WAS
SHARED IT IN DECEMBER BEFORE I
WAS GOING TO STEP DOWN AS
CHAIR. I RODE THE OF THE BUS
THE TWENTY TO THE HOTEL TWENTY
TWO WAS THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
BUS WHERE. A LOT OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS SLEEP ON AND- DIED
OF THE PURPOSE OF IT WAS KIND
OF GET A SENSE OF THOUGH THE-
THE VOLUME OF THE ISSUE AND
PEOPLE ARE SLEEPING ON THE BUS
AND- GETTING SOCIAL SERVICES
AND- TO THEM. BUT THE OTHER.
THING THAT I NOTICED WHEN I WAS
HEADING FOR PAUL ALSO ON THE
BUS THAT WAS COMING IN TO TWO
THIRTY IN THE MORNING. THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
WORKED ON THE BUS OR WORKING AT
RESTAURANTS THAT. DROPPED OFF
IN THE SAN JOSE. THEIR LIVING
THE STYLES A WORKING OF THOSE
RESTAURANTS WHEN I THINK ABOUT
EMPOWERING WORKERS. I THINK
ABOUT THOSE WORKERS AND WHAT AN
OPPORTUNITY. THEY WERE ABLE TO
GET THE TO BE MORE EMPOWERED IN
THEIR WORK. AT THAT THE WE CAN
REPEAT THAT AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES THAT
COOPERATIVES. ARE ACTIVATED NOW
AND SO THIS CONGRESS. VERY
PERSONAL I THINK A LOT OF US.
MEANINGFUL. AND I'M GRATEFUL.
TO HAVE SO MANY. MY CHIEF
CONSULTANT LABOR CAN BE MAKING
LANE AS WELL AS JUST A DEAL
AGREES PRINCIPLE CONSULTANT.
AND MY DISTRICT RECTOR STACY
SHE- BUT- AS WELL AS THE CITY
STAFF AND STATE STAFF. THAT
HELPED TO ORGANIZE THE AUDIO
VISUAL FOR TODAY'S EVENT AS
WELL. AND SO THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AGAIN THIS
IS THE FIRST. INFORMATION
HEARING SINCE I'VE BEEN CHAIR
LABOR. BECAUSE IT WILL BE LOOK
FOURTEEN TO HAVE MORE AGAIN
FOCUSING ON THE FUTURE. OF WORK
I THINK THAT THIS IS A GREAT
START. TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
AT THE CON IN OR WE KNOW WHERE.
THE STATE DOES DOES HAVE A LOT
MORE WORK TO DO WENT BUT I.
TRULY BELIEVE. THAT OUR SPEAKER
AND OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR AS WELL. WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE OF SOME OF THE IDEAS
WE BRING FORWARD BASED UPON.
THE CONVERSATIONS TODAY AND WAS
UPBEAT. WE CONTINUE GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH
BISHOP